you just showed up like you might need
some practice uh you going down for the
count it's going down tonight I do it
all for my family you do it all for the
likes I hear that Bell and I'm ready to
fight Turn Me Up Turn Me Up Turn Me Up
they want the boat they don't work and
no don't mess around end up hurting them
I say the wrong thing make it personal
you said hola amigos
off with a sad note but respect yeah
dude respect name of Sinead O'Connor
song Go I can't do it Ben you're you're
23 23. can't do it's also my favorite
Sinead O'Connor yeah
it was a banger no you don't know zombie
that was Sinead right I thought that was
the Cranberries
is she not you're good no I think he's
right though did she not sing zombie no
yeah that's not her that's cranberries
dogs cranberries yeah why ain't this a
[__] this we did not start what's your
favorite song yeah why are you putting
me in she hasn't she has that sad song
uh come on look at my brother you don't
know you know you're a big Sinead guy
well did she she did the opening uh
walkout for Connor yeah 189. yeah it's
like Rivers oh nothing compares to you
come on yeah don't say come on come on
come on fellas or uh
this is a rebel song or Troy this is the
day
it's like the one you like I want your
oh I dig that I'm big Emperor's New
Clothes guy emperor's new phone am I
right
um
fellas we're here UFC 291 thank you for
coming feels good to be here man
Mr Benjamin pumps baby thank you for
doing this youngest youngest guest ever
on the show this dude's 23. graduated
from ASU
how was that yeah it was fun man four
years number one party school in the
nation that's why he's got [__] 10
beers that's why I'm locked and loaded
10 beers and a turtleneck is two [__]
and his shoes ready dude he threw me off
with those shoes
it's loafers yeah a little gold keep it
classy dog dude top to bottom he came to
the show last night but you had a Blazer
on too I did oh there it is oh [__] damn
I can't wear the Blazers sitting in the
chair do you always dress like that of
course like is it or is it just for like
shows and podcasts no dude this is the
brand full-on I'll be dude so Las Vegas
last year International fight week it is
north of 110 degrees I'm rocking this
walking around the strip it was a
[__] terrible dude but you got to do
it when you're walking down the streets
dressed like that in Vegas do people
think you're a magician
um a magician straight up when I hit the
superhero part of the strip you know
what I mean yeah
yeah I dig it though man I
like the look now uh and you know this
too Ben uh Bradley Martin over here
trending right now
yeah I've been waiting to get into it so
good we don't want to go over this
[__] before the fight
we gotta dress it right now we gotta get
to it rally Martin right now my boy
Bradley is trending right now in the MMA
world
right now
I appreciate all of it yeah you love it
they hate you I love it I appreciate it
it's all good I love it now in it I
think the clip of us is on Twitter's at
over 8 million views now of you saying
uh I told you Mighty Mouse who beat you
up yeah now A little update on that I
spoke to Mighty Mouse yesterday yes
spoke to Mighty Mouse because he repost
the clip and I was like yo man and I I
tell everybody all fighters hit me up
about you I'm like Bradley's my boy good
dude yeah trolling awesome but he's
really humble works his ass off
discipline like you guys would anybody
who meets you is gonna love you like
there's a there's the Bradley you see on
YouTube or whatever on Instagram at zoo
culture who's the Bradley I know that's
got you know I like I like both of them
so I told uh mighty Mastermind I'm
telling you good dude dude and he's like
yeah no doubt he's like just tell him
I'm down he's like it's not gonna go
well I'm like no I know that's why I
wanted it to go down and he goes I have
to go on vacation I think he's going I'm
gonna say where he's going but he said
I'm going on vacation so let's let's
figure it out but I'll come to La I
can't just let me know I can't wait dude
at your Studios I'm like I'll figure out
some mats yeah sure man I saw Bradley
Marty outside beating up a homeless guy
that was crazy
that's only like Monday through to
Tuesday no but that is crazy okay so I
have a question yeah go for it when you
first were like challenging people to
street fights like why how did that come
about I was never challenging people to
street fights it was just kind of like I
knew that it would be a trust this is
how it started I asked I asked David
Haney just because I knew that I get a
reaction right I knew that people
because I know people were always
divided by that versus like obviously
I'm not a trained professional Devin
Haney fighting his whole life right
Devin Haney I will Devin Haney I do
think you put a beat down on I I'm an
adult not in boxing uh this is not so
yeah no no not about it
in a ring he would beat the shot
everybody at the same time I'm gonna
triple down on that one I think I could
beat him in a street fight okay I agree
ads was a complete troll yeah that one
that one felt like a controller I before
that podcast that's what that's what he
[__] up right you know that's what he
[__] up for sure because well the also
natives Roy like where we come from Nate
is royalty so like when you did that
that's when the fan base like that's our
man so I kind of like the double down on
NATO I kind of I was like no no no the
triple down on uh on on Haney this is
not I never not double down on Nate Nate
I knew because I had I had met Nate
multiple times before this is good dude
and I I had the idea going into it I was
like I'm gonna ask him if he was Chief
like who'd win a street fight and I was
thinking I was gonna see if he would
like actually try to like because I feel
like he's kind of got to try to fight me
on the spot he's a rattlesnake yeah I
feel like he'd be like get up right now
dude he's like out of all the guys you
called out he's like the one of the
legit ones like oh really I'm not even
be mad about him let's go let's see how
you do so that's why I did it um
obviously like I'm not trying to fight
in ideas no you know what I'm saying
um so it's definitely a troll and then
and then I just kept playing with it and
then when obviously I talked to you
about it yeah it's just it's funny to me
and people's reactions is great I think
that's that's because like the people's
reactions is where like oh this is kind
of you know oh weird it sounds like you
know what you're doing it all weird it
sounds like you know what you're doing
for clicks and you know what I'm saying
for views and like it's also so good
it's just it's just entertaining because
a lot of people are actually like oh
Bradley would kill Mighty Mouse so
Bradley would kill Nate Diaz look how
big he is look how strong is he lifts
all this weight and then the the people
that on our side like no dude like this
there's also yeah and there's also like
there's like I was talking to you on my
pod there's also that air to like just
the uncertainty of it I'm not talking
about being in a ring and fighting these
guys in a [__] ring it's on the
street yeah I'm talking about like there
is an heir to like who [__] knows
obviously the chances they're that's
they're they're very low it'll be
funnier if you weren't big and athletic
and that's why 250 pounds
right well I mean I've lost every time
he actually did this it wouldn't have
the same effect though like no reason
why it's so divisive because you have
people off off bat or just like oh yeah
he's huge look at him but like they
don't you know they don't understand the
details well I think also because it's
you because it's like Bradley Martin you
know what I mean like I think that
really is where yeah um I will say this
though I think any ranked flyweight
could probably take you in a street
fight any 125 or maybe even unranked
dude I think there's a couple dogs
outside the top 15. I don't know that's
my take on it I think I'm gonna start
just I yeah I don't know about that
Mighty Mouse for sure my name is what
about him because he's just so well
versed in everything he's the guy some
refer to him as the goat it's either him
or Jon Jones there's a debate for either
I mean Jon Jones like that's kind of
easy for me I feel like I give it to Jon
Jones Mighty you know I love you I give
to Jon Jones because he's fighting a
heavier weight class there's more
there's less room for air so I always
end the level of competition
as we go so I usually give it to John
for pound for pound but there's the
argument for Mighty Mouse all day Mighty
Mouse is just it's gonna be tough dude
and he's in like I was talking he's like
yeah I've grapple with 300 Pounders and
that's where my perspective is I do
these people when they come through like
the amateur and the pro ranks even
before the UFC like they likely are
getting rounds with huge [__]
and and fighting so many guys like like
me and your boy Pettis me and pedis are
all together yeah like when I was in the
UFC yeah yeah he's he's small for me and
Anthony he's probably holding his own
you know what I mean yeah yeah ground
yes but it is it's such a funny [__]
joke though because of how much it stirs
people I love it it is pretty fun I'll
be honest man like I just did Jiu Jitsu
today and I've done I've like I've
dabbled here and there I've spent some
time more consistently than others and I
just want to say first and foremost I
have so much respect for people who do
it because it's not it's not what people
think it is which is why I think that
the community who's in it gets so riled
up because they know what it is yeah and
then you see like comments that go it's
just a big dumb jock I'm like that
doesn't work here just because he works
out in the gym has muscles he can't be
done he's entrepreneur I've also been to
a YouTube self-made it doesn't work I'm
also a YouTuber no no don't forget about
that I'm doing the internet [__] for 13
years and doing well at it I own two
gyms like I just have a Southern Company
I have a payroll company like I've I've
done everything so so that does that
narrative doesn't work it's like just
like you didn't do your research on
Mighty Mouse they're not doing the
research on you so I'm like saying he's
a big Meathead doesn't work here you
gotta run with something else it would
be funny if they've got you locked in
like a DARS and you're like I have a
supplement company
I'm just saying like
this is why I think it's important to
drink because obviously the Mighty Mouse
stuff the Nate Diaz stuff the uh Haney
stuff all fun and games but then Logan
Paul Two Shots yeah and then I was like
that's why I told him like well that's a
possibility like you're never gonna
fight Mighty Mouse you're not fighting
Diaz yeah Haney's never gonna do it
Logan Paul can get it though meaning and
Logan's a buddy but I'm just saying like
he's in that world that same world as
you are yeah where that could actually
potentially happen yeah well the thing
the thing about that that I just found
interesting was it was like his call out
was based on the fact that I wanted to
see his brother get memed and he was mad
that like I know them which this gets
ironic because it's like well if I know
them and you know me and you had really
a problem with what I was saying just
text me yeah so for you to say this is
my thing for for him to say I care about
views and I'm trying to get views but
then if you really had a problem you
could have said yo what the [__] but you
just said it for views and then you also
said it to promote your upcoming fight
like in his own words yeah so that's why
I was like this is [__] lame like
you're in this fight Camp you want to
use me as a sparring partner to promote
your fight if you really just want to
fight I'll just fight yeah well and the
hypocrisy kind of extends when his main
business partner is one of Jake's Rivals
you know what I'm saying right a dude
who's got years of like beef with and
like yeah and Logan's like yeah I'll
just start a company with him you know
what I mean yeah and Jake and his own
words talks about feeling a little bit
like hurting that so like for him to
jump out to defend his brother against
me over some stupid [__] like you're
playing Glass House man yeah I just want
to see him get mean Logan was upset
about because tell me you you said that
you were talking to Haney or Nate Diaz
you're like I want Jake to lose because
you want to see him as a man yeah would
you wear to say if he's your buddy I'm
with Logan on that a little bit goddamn
dog yeah but like I could still like
Jake but want to see him get memed and
even at the end of that it because
people don't watch the whole thing they
just watch the clips yeah there's no
contract so even at the end of that
interview with Nate I was talking about
wanting to see Jake get meme just
because he meme Tyrone just because he
mean all these people been asking and
then I said I was talking I was talking
to Nate I was like but also you don't
lose because you're going to get [__]
memed if if he if Jake knocks you out
you get mean he did not like that
nates won't be as bad though because the
MMA culture will protect Nate he's like
I mean he's our Lord he's like he's like
Trump for maggots you know what I'm
saying yeah he's the best yeah he's
apparently he's moving uh out in L.A so
I'm gonna do some I already talked to
him like when he comes back after the
fight I'm gonna [__] do some rolling
do something yeah
I'm gonna challenge himself
okay actually I'm curious though so you
wanted him get memed in the sense of
like not like a meme knockout but just
like mean by the community no no they're
being knockout like oh okay I'm just
trying to give you an out what I mean
we're like they they when he knocks him
out and then they fall into that like
that kind of [__] yeah and the meme kind
of goes into space and [__] I just think
that shit's funny because you want to
like because Jake does that to the other
guy exactly and so I want to say but
wouldn't you be cheering for Jay because
Jake's more from your world
yeah but like like him doing to Ben
asker and Woodley like that hurt my
feelings because you know they're my
world but the YouTubers are like oh my
God just do it it's like holy [__] we
talked about this Jake's now a fighter
correct so it's like but his
background's still yeah like like
business hilarious like him and business
are going out in DMS and businessman
he's like all right Disney boy like all
right does he just comes because he was
on the Disney Channel forget about that
damn like you're never he's never gonna
Escape that like but he's but he's more
of a fighter than me than KSI than Logan
and all these 100 so I agree with that
yeah I think Jake's Head and Shoulders
above like we were talking like if he
loses this fight is he gonna continue
fighting then we'll find out if because
it's all fun and games when you're
making 40 million and you're selling the
place out and winning fights when if he
he lost his last one he loses this one
let's say he gets marked on this one I
think we'll find out if he actually
truly loved fighting or if he was just
doing it for something to do if he loses
again and then like that's it he hangs
it up well it's tough because it puts
everything else he's done in a different
light because then it's like oh well you
really weren't about it you know
is going to leave too like those big
names aren't going to entertain man
imagine if he got that fight bro the
Conor fight if he wins this if he wins
this that's right there bro that is the
most insane the Conor fights right there
the Sam Albie fights right there
dude I just I'm telling you he fought
Conor that'd be that'd be insane if only
if he beats Nate and here's the other
thing you think he knows this obviously
of course he knows what he's doing he's
brilliant with that stuff but if he
beats Nate Nick Diaz is there who's
available the older brother so revenge
tour there and they got Connor like like
he's gonna make so much freaking money
if he can just get past and ideas that's
a big if though so it's a [__]
let's say he loses he's still I think
he's still gonna box and you still make
a massive bat because he has such a
fight like a KSI but the like you're not
getting the Connors
influencer he's going back to the
concert you have to go back to YouTube
yeah real Fighters I'm like nah because
case sci-fi is still huge though the KSI
five is still a pretty big one I didn't
realize how big KSI it was he's huge I
didn't realize how big he was yeah dude
straight up the English [__]
they love that guy yeah he's like the
biggest YouTuber in the UK since Prince
Diana yeah crazy but also people like
him more than American I think the
biggest no dude how dare you this fight
no matter what happens the biggest fight
for Jake obviously he's Connor in the in
the in the real in the real world but I
think it's him fighting Logan is the
biggest fight boom there you go that's
the biggest fight Jake fighting Logan
yes and I think that's their plan I had
Logan on food truck and I was like it
was right before his first prize League
we plan to go with this I do too and he
was like well this this ain't in it and
I was like because you know you and your
brother make the most money he goes now
you're talking he said we've talked
about that like that's how this ends
yeah he's gonna do his thing I'm doing
mine then we fight each other and it
makes the most sense that's gonna be the
even if Jake loses the Nate no matter
what you're gonna fight no matter what
and that does gangbuster numbers
and I think like I would love to see
that yeah that's interesting yeah let's
go man I go kyosa out of Aurora Colorado
you [__] dude I gotta read it I know
you hate when I read the channel I gotta
read the chat bro they're probably
saying he's 260 though bro I know
they're saying that I'm a chess Grand
Master dude that was one of my favorites
you're probably gonna get a lot of MMA
fans on there who aren't gonna favor you
but if your fans are on there then like
you have you ever seen Bradley deadlift
a thousand pounds with his nuts or
whatever we've got a deadlift behind the
yeah
deadlifts like yeah
bro this is amazing hold on Ben you got
a you got a A Winner here with kiessa
and uh Kevin Holland it's tough because
I like both guys I'm a huge Cass event
yeah I mean Granny's from my hometown
but even before that I didn't know he's
from Aurora now I'm even a bigger fan
but he was my Dark Horse to be world
champion at I'm kidding yeah yeah wow he
had a good run man I mean he had some
really underrated wins the Neil Maggie
when I think the RDA won a couple years
back
um back in the day too yeah but years on
the sidelines I think he's interested in
a lot of other things particularly the
broadcasting side he's good at it and
he's he's amazing at him he's really
good at it you know coming back against
an opponent like Kevin Holland I think
is a big [__] problem
yeah sorry they said Brad vs Rampage
God damn I don't know I didn't think
that because you know I'm with Rampage
we we do the UFL stuff together Rampage
is finding a guy named Daryl schoonover
when that's who I should say this that's
who he wants to fight Daryl schoonover
was on my season Ultimate Fighter season
10. yeah he got bullied by Rampage
because Rampage called him titties so
Rampage was on food truck and I I was
trying to tell Rampage to fight somebody
else Bob Sapp who's his buddy and he's
like I want to fight scoon over because
we have that beef I'm like bro Skinner
isn't fighting like nine years dude I
think he works at like Uber or something
don't do that but he's like that's why I
want to fight so I think they're trying
to figure that deal out
Rampage but then it'd be it'd be in a
cage dog yeah [__] but Rampage is Big
right now he's gonna hate on saying this
he's big not like oh not like big big
he's like big big he's like lizzo thick
and then there's like cool there's a
rampage
but he's gonna he went to Thailand Los
Angeles they did The Leverage
look at that yeah well that's the
easiest lift though Rampage is a
[__] too bro he hits like a Mack
truck
Galaxy sport he's in Japan right now is
he actually yeah that's [__] with his
kids yeah Rampage is my favorite yo
realistic one of my closest people
realistically you know how like
everyone's like oh Jake feisty's older
guys who are like on the way out type
[__] what he did to Anderson was so
impressive absolutely so impressive how
much weaker do you think
they're like he's getting like do you
think it's his punch strength is down no
I don't I don't think his strength it
down so that's the last thing to leave I
think his speed and uh Reaction Time
Reaction Time correlation yeah
durability after his UFC stand there's
just like a there is a decline like you
can there's a tangible okay this isn't
the rampage that we knew you know like
they took it off the card as the main
card supposed to be Wonderboy Thompson
who's 40. yeah he's supposed to fight
this uh other guy uh Pierre Michelle
Pierre and Michelle Pierre didn't make
weight so most Fighters like [__] y'all
still beat him up but Wonderboy at Ford
he's like nah I'm good I find his big
ass well straight up like at 40 but also
he did that against Darren till years
before with till missed weight and
Wonderboy was like I'm a Gangster I'll
[__] fight him anyways he lost by a
bit of a slit decision yeah so he's like
[__] it I'm switching at 40 because he
loses this one you go back the bottom of
the queue and it's a that division is a
beast so he's gonna have to work his way
back up at 40. I'm with him he's like
was he running six or seven I think
seven and Michelle's dude Michelle's 29
nine so you're talking about 11 years
age difference I'm not going to give you
weight I'm not going to give you a more
Advantage but here's my thing I hope the
UFC done in discipline because they're
like wait you're not gonna fight and
he's like no they didn't pay Michelle
that's that's [__] up that's not the
way and as much money as they make don't
get me starting this has to be like the
same thing with weightlifting where it's
like you slow down it slows down like
the less you're training yes the faster
it slows down 100 because so like what
about May weather like is he just
because every time I see like he's into
some like even like a exhibition match
he's fighting like sparring partners
though literally like and it's like no
risk and he's also a defensive fighter
when he fought Logan like he did he he
did pretty good yeah yeah he's always
gonna do pizza Logan has 30 pounds on
him
yeah but you know Logan you're talking
about a master that might be the best
boxer of all time yeah yeah even if he
was 70 he's gonna give Logan problems he
just knows the country before he comes
so crazy this fight's nuts wow come on
man Kevin Holland's been more active
exactly
his fight against freaking uh Hamza was
this guy looks way leaner than I've ever
seen him this time yeah yeah he's he has
a podcast too he's entertaining he's
super into town oh Holland's dope joke
on the ground either his wrestling
obviously is the issue but he's a black
belt on the ground Holland by sub is
plus 500 I've been all over that line
this entire time
uh yeah I mean you're better listen gang
I'm not better oh I love that I love
that my producer
Gambler man dude I'm a penny partner
like guy you know I'm putting up dollars
here two bucks there because I don't
have that huge of a bankroll
um but I was also fresh out of college
I'm also I'm also broke uh I got a
[__] turtleneck that but I gotta turn
that yes there's there's places to go
this is all of my money maybe maybe it's
from my childhood I see turtleneck I
think you're loaded yeah it might be
because bad guys from James Bond or
whatever but yeah his hair's got me like
this guy's got money for sure they're
here in the Turlock
I'm wearing the net worth right now
don't worry I'll send you uh uh cash app
for the modellas we should have bought
those did we buy those he brought his
own models oh we bought him oh thank God
holy [__] straight up people I got a
six-pack did you just take one turn neck
off and have another one underneath
what's up wait you have two turtlenecks
on wait hold on a second
dude Legend bro wait wait wait
because that was that was amazing I have
been sitting all day with two
turtlenecks on how did I not notice that
it's just in case you swept one out you
didn't want to pass yeah I was like you
know I'll wear them all that was amazing
I didn't see that coming
damn this guy's good dude so when my car
was locked up at the construction site
I'm wearing two turtlenecks now just
sitting outside that Brad versus
turtleneck
plus 500 baby who said it who said it
all right give me a little steam it's
good man would you win like four hundo I
won like three bucks
ain't about the size it's about to win
the win baby that's tough though man I
would assume chaos is done because you
gotta realize that kiss all things
grappling that you know getting
submitted by Vicente Luke not Kevin
Hollings probably like [__] I'm out
well here's he knows that defense he he
does but also like at his age I feel
with with maybe the decrease in training
and focus on MMA like he should be
fighting older guys he should be
fighting some you know not dudes like
Kevin Holland who are still threats I
agree but he wants to be well he says
you got to get through guys like Kevin
Holland that's true
what is he look at he's talking [__] oh
he's going you can't [__] with me Doug
he goes you ain't gonna sub me
yeah gamesmanship come on little little
break down your fights coming up
I don't think this guy stands he's
actually he's leaving this and he's
going right after the analysts yes it
just says you're gonna be World Champ so
I think he has been like be cool man
you're gonna be World Champ unless you
fight harms out again then you know
mom's out to 85 now what do you think of
hamzat and Apollo costume oh what do I
think about the guy that showed up eight
and a half pounds overweight to the kind
of like a layup in a pay-per-view Main
Event right yeah maybe not the best
opinions of all time he's a talented
animal you know what I mean but like
Costa is a freak too and here's the
thing if you're struggling to take down
Gilbert Burns a puffed up lightweight as
much as I love Burns he's a crazy
welterweight costume or he's number two
at the time because it's a middleweight
that guy is a true 185. yeah I don't
know I love that guy no Amazon
I love that guy no power to you more
power
we should bet on it yeah you tell me
Doug uh five dollars
ten turtlenecks
can come in different shape but you look
at Paulo's fight with Luke rockhold you
can't tell me that guy beats calms that
was a weird fight I was very surprised
by how Paulo approached that and how
that one was actually see I think's
fighting against Gilbert Burns was a
weird fight because he was so arrogant
so cocky sound the cage and then just
decided to brawl with him it's like dude
what are you doing bro yeah no it's he
still won though that's the thing I
guess the number two welterweight in the
world but I think he we saw cracks
because up until like there were Burns
fight again people were saying
Untouchable is the just a beast you know
what I'm saying
governments are like listen you're not
you know what I mean you're a human's
gangster though straight up yeah he's
also really funny on Twitter apologize
yes
but his account got taken down really
yeah talking too much [__] probably no
you know what it was he would post like
street fights or like people getting hit
by cars and stuff yeah wow yeah but no
Lewis right on my eyes yeah okay yeah
yeah he's okay but then people like flat
haters like flagged it like this person
died so then on Twitter Instagram yes
Instagram took his face down you know
Twitter Twitter open on my Twitter I see
girls sucking dick I mean Jesus right
but if I say the wrong word I get
demonetized no dude Twitter actually
just released monetization yeah I know
the ad sharing literally [__] shout
out Elon Musk man I just love that plan
but then they changed it today it's X
like everything's to the X it's X now
what is it what is it called when you
Tweet now
it's porn excellent yeah he's funny he's
funny that name change he really is well
he's like XVideos when he was uh when he
was at PayPal bro he was trying to
rename PayPal X and that's why they
kicked him out of paypals because
they're like uh musk that's a dumb name
he even started PayPal yeah yeah he was
one of the guys he's like no he was like
on the ground floor
he's brilliant no he's a he's an
interesting kg let us know if Kevin
Holland says anything of no bud you know
this headline says Twitter starts paying
but only Elon musk's favorite creators
I'm in that list baby yeah Brad man it
should be on that list it's a dope I'm
an Elon fan big fan man that it is funny
because like the people on Twitter that
would just [__] post their way to get
engagement and Impressions they're
getting paid for it now I think it's so
stupid but what's weird is uh what was
the what was the thing that um Mark
Zuckerberg created the threats that
thing's down 60 yeah it went it went it
didn't make sense to me like hold on
it's the exact same thing but it's like
I feel like he just did it on purpose
well they he did it because he thought
like you know all the like woke liberal
people like yeah we have freedom over
here and they're like yeah no one's
following us over here yeah well there's
no Discovery did you see the yeah
there's no Discovery and then did you
see the all the stuff you give obviously
I'm on Instagram anyways so like [__] I
can't even knock Zuckerberg but when you
sign up for Threads it's like give them
all of your information that wasn't the
biggest like no I'm good
oh God
was a beast she should get the next time
shot
I wonder
every time you invite me to do this show
Steve invites me to go to the UFC
I'm sorry man no I can no you should
probably be no no no you did a [__]
solid for me and I needed it yeah and I
could not let you down thanks brother
no I would never I would I just remember
it's like always like I didn't know
cheeto's not here Tito had an emergency
at the crib he I don't give too much
away but it was an issue he got here
late I'm like dude be with your family
Bradley was going to challenge him to a
fight and we just couldn't happen he was
afraid
Cheeto ducky bro I'm sorry honestly dude
now you're scaring people away dude
don't tell him I'm coming
invite like heavyweights
[Laughter]
it's less than two six okay I got you
John that's the number baby yeah
there he is Big Johnny boy yeah but with
that with the threads thing too they're
like look how many users we have I'm
like yeah because yeah it's just the
whoever follows you on Instagram it goes
right over there yeah it's such a weird
vibe yeah I got it I'm not mad when Mark
Zuckerberg eats [__] though I don't I
just don't I don't know after watching
The Social Network yeah I've never
really been a fan yeah
I started more with the twins
I feel like threads could have been like
a good answer if they had added some
Discovery or like more functionality
they will or just something but or just
some of that or just something different
though too like when it came out it
stressed me out like ah another social
media Platform One to figure out you
know so but like the reason Tick Tock
works because it's different than
Instagram the reason Instagram work is
different than Twitter if it's just the
exact same thing but not as good why why
did you think that was gonna be a good
idea
you have to look at the history though
of Instagram it was like they I love
Instagram Instagram's my favorite player
that's why I started all my [__] right
yeah but he went on you didn't start on
Vine or some [__] no I started on
Instagram and then I went to YouTube
never on Vine I think it was on Vine for
a minute I didn't know how to make any
sort of like Fitness related content
because that's all I made back then
seconds you can't do much yeah yeah
I could have there was content I made in
the future on Instagram that I could
have done but I just wasn't even in that
space then but Instagram originally took
stories they took so much stuff from
other platforms like Snapchat was the
only stories right yeah Snapchat was
just stories but that was all they had
that was all they had and then Instagram
took it and everyone was like I heard
Snapchat's still popping like I had some
dude tell me how much money made on
Snapchat I was like wait why are you
making money Snapchatting away the most
money Snapchat you don't have a show on
Snapchat no no I gotta hook you up I
have enough you have a show on Snapchat
I have two shows on Snapchat what and I
have uh and I'm I'm through their
creator programs street fights on
Snapchat street fights I fought Nate
Snapchat
regular people
I'm just a horrible person
at Target man they give me a wrong look
I [__] them bro I was gonna go get mats
and just challenge people
are so viral right now 100 bucks that
would be pretty like a college campus or
some [__] man 24-Hour Fitness yeah but
I'm trying to figure out do I do I do
boxing gloves or like UFC gloves bare
Knuckles no gloves
liabilities here are just completely
[__] why now if we get math and you
have just your boys around like it's
like Lionheart with Van Damme so the
human bodies are like that would be such
funny content that would be actually so
funny but anyways you like your weird
grimy promoter with like a [__]
turtleneck let me see just [__] get
the hair up yeah dude damn but so you
the the Snapchat says there yeah so
Snapchat is is is one of the platforms
that pays the most like they pay so much
to creators I'll tell you off here who I
talked to about it and it's just like
the number one guy on Snapchat when he
told me like how much little work it
requires in the shows on there and
there's also no suppression like yes on
on YouTube there is though like you
can't you can't do certain explicit
stuff like there's certain guidelines
like they will really yeah you can't
bang dudes on this yeah well that's it
yes I win
[Laughter]
only fans is kind of they're trying to
get out of the adult they do the porn
stuff obviously but there's like a lot
of UFC fighters like check out my only
fans at first you know I'm 40 I was like
wait they're sucking dick on there like
no [__] yeah I'm showing my training
you idiot like oh yeah the only fans
originally started it was actually to
people who were making like a uh just a
paywall for Fitness content that was how
it originally started and then the owner
was like we need to make money someone
was like
platform how about you do anal yeah but
for porno I don't know how it goes for
porno stars they don't need like
braziers or whatever a studio or no they
can just do it and they own it all they
don't have to give a cut to anybody can
do it out of your body cut to only fans
but yeah yeah but you're not you're not
paying a producer
dude that's like yeah
[__] yeah exactly I don't know if
there's casting for that but could you
imagine
that's funny no only fans it is
interesting how they're trying to Branch
out it's never gonna work like you can't
separate I feel like you can't separate
only fans from the adult yeah once you
go down so far exactly they try to at
one point I remember they were like
we're gonna like not let this happen as
much and like their [__] tanked
everyone's like no remember they stop uh
porn on there because the you know why
because the banks because the bank's
like we don't condone this so the banks
once they allow so they wanted to get
more funding to raise more Capital yeah
and the bank's like nah with porn We're
Not Gonna JP Morgan was like I don't
think so yeah yeah U.S Bank was like nah
there's all some people take three dicks
meanwhile meanwhile they're all
subscribed
that's what happened and then they just
tanked and they're like our bat porno
stars come back yeah before the porno
stars like it's a good business move
because you're taking out the middleman
exactly you own all your content like
they don't own in their content Jenna
Jameson why I know all this is weird but
Jenna Jameson was the first porno star
like no I own the IP yeah my bodies
10 years wow yeah if this goes south or
my everybody
I consider that if all my [__] goes
south dude I'll do some weird feeds yeah
fair enough
definitely show them my dick though yeah
it would have to you know what's it true
because like a lot of only fans uh
creators they also live in just like the
coolest [__] places like I do a
showdown in Colombia and Medellin Bogota
is filled with only fans creators yeah
and they have those asses and stuff dude
beautiful wow I'd love to go to Club
what are you doing when you go down
there play by play um
you rock the Turlock in Columbia yes sir
everything let's get a dry fit one do
you do mock turtlenecks only the long so
Steve Jobs
turtleneck if somebody's like a midterm
it's like you're not full Turtle oh okay
nah I got a full turtle come on dude go
full Steve Jobs straight up man give me
the glasses
throw some glasses on that guy yeah it's
Ben Davis and Steve Jobs I'll tell you
what um somebody did say like a
sleeveless turtleneck would be pretty
funny like in Florida because
you're gonna call me
bro oh here we go this is the last fight
of Tony Ferguson's career gents yeah
you're gonna hope so you should I'm
surprised to get another fight did you
see his uh pre-fight uh conference where
he's like I'm gonna get five fights in
the title I watched it I felt and I
loved it he's he is one of the unsung
heroes of the lightweight division in my
in my personal opinion well why are you
guys counting out right now because he's
on a four fight losing streak he's been
finishing his last 75 in fight years
yeah he's 75 years old and he just had
he doesn't look great you know although
he didn't look terrible starting
interrupting yeah you're looking
terrible against Chandler until he got
caught with that Spartan Kick but before
you know the first one was okay first
round was all right I think you got to
realize Bradley he he won 12 fights in a
row you supposed to fight khabib and
khabib got hurt could be way it just
then he was on the UFC Fox set walking
off blew his knee out oh that's gotta
[__] be terrible if he's like just
I'm trying to imagine being in that
position there's a point at one time
when he was the baddest one
there's an argument like we didn't know
he matched up very well with khabib it
just never happened in the prime that
[__] sucks man so yeah it's a fight
we never got it was but not not even one
time not even twice but like four times
yeah four or five times where he was
supposed to fight khabib he has a win
over RDA when RDA was like in my opinion
probably at his pee I agree you know
what I'm saying and so like Tony
I mean Bobby green is like he's a tough
matchup because of the the low hands and
the straight shots but he's explosive
too so when you're a veteran and here's
the other thing this is the difference
between Nate Diaz and Tony Ferguson both
have the same miles on them but Nate
adapt to his style and his style is not
based off of explosive and athleticism
Tony style you got to be young and
athletic like his movement and all that
the wrestling all that yeah yeah yeah so
like unorthodox when you get older that
goes out the window so it's an awful
fight for him because Bobby's so
explosive and Tony's not anymore and the
thing he's the biggest dog on the card
yeah which makes sense minus 410 I think
is a favorite and you look just massive
in MMA yeah I was just reading chat and
and they said you looked more jackedant
recently have you been doing something
different
it's in the waist baby I had a Whopper
with my brother
have you been drinking have you been
doing like
train anymore nah she's living right
he's getting back I swim a lot I ride my
bike more than anything yeah well they
say you look more Jacks I'll take it
dude thanks thanks fellas yeah they're
good they're nice in the chat are they
because it's usually she's Jack but gay
like they're not nice to me dude please
quit yeah don't tell me anymore no no I
won't yeah I just he's lying every
comment it's like he's like no dude they
like you yeah they love you dude he's
gotten seven death threats why do you
think people like to talk [__] about you
about me yeah uh I do I do a lot of
shows
um a lot of the audience was introduced
for me on The Ultimate Fighter where I
was a cocky fighter which you got to be
when you fight so they Nev they for them
it's tough if you're put in a box it's
tough for them to separate that so if
they've been following me since the
ultimate fighter UFC days when yeah I
thought I was gonna win every fight and
knock everybody out that's how you got
to be as a fighter yeah so oh he's
arrogant no I'm not it was a job and
then you transition where most Fighters
stop you know once they stop fighting
they you know they go on to open a gym
or do it and there's nothing wrong with
that I went to something completely
different started going comedy podcast
yeah now you're gonna stand up it's just
it's just not natural so it's it's it
and I do a lot of content for people to
hate on yeah and I give and I have a lot
of opinions that's why I have a
successful podcast I have a lot of
opinions so a lot of people saying a lot
of people [__] with it a lot of people
don't but either way you're talking
about it yeah it's almost like we have
the same sort of thing like the fight
career and everything
[Laughter]
say this there's a great quote from Pete
Weber who was a pro bowler back in the
day and he was like hate me love me all
you could do is watch yeah that's all
you could [__] do you see on the
sidelines you chat [__] but at the end
of the day I'm not that arrogant about
it but yeah Pete Webber's a beast he was
a man dude you talk [__] who do you
think you are what do you think it was
at a 12 year old he was that was
directed at a [__] kids dude what
I know and I apologize I do have to
apologize to the community because as
soon as you I said on the Pod just
because naturally I didn't it didn't
come to mind right away and then
afterwards I went and looked at it
because I looked him up and I was like
oh I've seen this guy fight that's like
me if it's like the bodybuilding world
not that you're so into that but that'd
be like me not knowing who Ronnie
Coleman is yeah or Arnold Schwarzenegger
you'd be like what no not Arnold that's
like not knowing Arnold Arnold was a
governor bro Arnold
Arnold not in the movies Arnold when he
was uh winning Mr Universe he's like
what really that's all right when you
were like oh [__] I'm sorry I'm gonna
have him on the Pod and we're going to
[__] that's awesome I'm telling you I
set it up I touch you and he's a good
like he's not gonna come at you mean or
try to hurt you like he's a good dude
yeah
I mean if we did a street fight
how much you weigh not 260. no he's like
I actually don't know my body fat I need
to go though
talk about that that's fair
did you watch that Arnold documentary
The End by meow he's all by himself at
house Fair well I told Brian that he
goes don't spoil it for me like how do I
spoil he says do you think it's what the
[__] how's it going to use Governor
Brian's like don't spoil I'm like oh hey
spoil Oppenheimer I'm gonna be really
mad yeah yeah dude you don't know what
happened
[Laughter]
Tony's kind of putting the work in I
don't know if we've seen the last two
yeah he's looking good I'm putting the
organ man I love Bobby but it's hard not
to root for Tony man he's a OG dude
his training's nuts I'll say this I love
Bobby's facial hair man that was the
[__]
you know dude Bobby was on food truck I
don't know if we come
get him oh oh he got him
come on Tony and I love Bobby so I'm not
ruining this but I just straight up
they're both good dude they're both good
dudes but it's hard to read against them
dude I had Bobby on food truck and he
grew up wild like super wild he's like
you've never played uh hide and get it
uh
[Music]
because Bobby was like we're talking
it's a great interview and he goes you
never played hide and get it as a kid
I'm like hide and seek he's like nah man
I didn't get it so be like three of my
friends right three boys three girls
then we'd find them and then we'd have
sex with them
I was like no I think you're thinking of
hide and seek goes no bro how old how
old are you I think he said eight no no
no no yeah yeah no there's no way I'm
telling you we had to have the episode
because the sex part is get it that's it
that's the getting it oh yeah I didn't
grow up different time man yeah
different times wow that's hilarious
you're playing hide and get him I've
never heard of that
he's he's just a character man
this is not again really good dude not
that any eye poke is great you know no
iPhone is like oh excellent
I think it should it should be a warrant
should be an automatic point it's stupid
when it's like all right don't do that
again you compromise him he has one eye
now don't do that again you do it again
like all right dude we gave you a
warning one more we're taking a point
like if there's a bad eye shot or bad
nut shot or bad defense grab fence grab
something like a dick yeah how many
points is that it should be one point so
if you won the round it'd be a nine nine
round too bad I'm gonna take 30 points
away from you
we had one of the best in the business
he actually officiated my grappling
match oh [__] Dan's a man yeah Dan's a
great guy big big Dan
he's the best when you're heavyweight
he's a big dude so you know exactly you
don't want Keith Peterson in there he
can't do much for the heavyweights man
he's like also let you die
Keith's a violence dog oh
[__]
let's go Tony I know dude my uh [__] I
mean I was such when I was like getting
into mixed martial arts I'll be up front
what year uh again it was like 2017
2018. it's all 2022. I was a big
McGregor guy man I'll tell you what oh
yeah we watched we watched 229 and
Ferguson and Pettis was just a banger of
a fight I was like [__] hey dude
now is Connor actually gonna fight
Chandler yeah yeah UFC do exemption for
him when you saw it it happens
you don't think so I don't know I don't
think I just it's hard to believe that
it's gonna actually come to fruition
it's hard because all kind of posts like
him partying exactly yeah
they're just Polar Opposites why didn't
he cash out that that power 12 yeah yeah
and then UFC pays them all the money but
I I think I don't I still see Connor
going out like you went out with that
broken leg I I do think it happens
that's hard I think the main exemption
but just looking at his training and I'm
you know Connor was such a fun time so I
hold it dear to my heart and I love
Connor but yeah you see me tough for him
to beat Chandler after seeing it and
would you watch Ultimate Fighter I was
just about to bring it
I was every week I would tweet the
results and it would just be Conor
McGregor oh and one on The Ultimate
Fighter Conor McGregor oh and two on
this team won one fight the entire
season he's about to be the only the
only coach ever to go to get swept but
that's because again like you were
saying the theme is Veterans versus
prospects bad idea you're getting it's a
horrible idea you got guys Austin thud
Hubbard who have seven UFC fights taking
on a dude who's never fought in the UFC
is Tony getting licked yeah he got
licked in yeah
he's getting dicey my boy my boy Aaron
McKenzie
get out of there Tony ah
you see the speed difference
he's he's click he's yeah his speed
doesn't really deteriorate over the
rainbow that I did especially
there is good old bread
yes you know him and Oliveira is like
friendship who's the cut man Brad and uh
Charles Oliver they've got like the
funniest [__] Bromance after Charles
I think it was one of Charles's title
defenses he went and just [__] lifted
Brad up you see how big that
[__] is and Charles just like
dude he just like baby brother dude he
started with us he was a male nurse and
he was with Rashad all the time and he
was just our boy yeah this guy I know
he's like working for the UFC and you're
like what the [__] I was like what like
I was I was like fighting crocon I've
seen him putting faster I'm like what
the [__] are you doing now what's up
yeah he's like what's up dude bro hey
best luck in that second round
would you Brad would you actually have
like a mixed martial arts fight I need
some time to train for but yeah
absolutely yeah I'd love to yeah any
[__] promotion would put you main
event
any promotion I don't know if the UFC
not the UFC
let me just help you out maybe UFC one
pfl Bellator maybe not them but like LFA
that's the Bradley Martin Show baby yeah
it's a good show you you do you cut down
and wait like let's say Logan Paul's
like all right Brad let's do this yeah
I think naturally training for it I
would have to come down here just
because like my training would change
would it be like you know it's not about
being big
I think I'd probably end up around 240
235 yeah yeah so you wouldn't be able to
make light heavyweight then you'd have
to be oh it's not for him it's too thick
days
what do you what's your diet looking
like on like a day-to-day basis right
now sure yeah sure I don't need enough
to be honest man I've always been a
light eater which people probably do not
believe that but like I I don't need too
much yeah I fast most of the day
no I'm sorry I think you're better than
us
and McDonald's
I normally like two things right now two
big meals and then I'll snack you know
but when you when you like uh what's
your go-to when it's like a cheat meal
oh man it's like the rock probably
no like I really like desserts I'm a big
dessert you know like like fast food
like burgers or Chick-fil-A or nothing I
just I like I like hearty stuff like
that but like that stuff will make me
really feel like [__] if it's like just
heavily processed you do like a dessert
though like ice cream and [__] yeah like
like a Pazuki oh I love it oh yeah
just warm cookies and ice cream man so
good yeah I love that combo myself I
can't eat anymore because I have bad
teeth but [__] yeah but you could eat
[__] burgers and [__] uh if the
ketchup hits my teeth right it's a
nightmare what happens to your teeth
anything with sugar and it ruins my
teeth what's from that what caused that
uh nicotine that'll do it I think so
yeah
I have to use like a super sensitive uh
toothpaste and Sensodyne yeah
boy that guy no I have the medical grade
though
it's so insane wow it starts I started
using that charcoal toothpaste because
someone told me it's better for me it's
not though he's not fluoride in it so
you get the enamel and your teeth wear
out damn I got problems yeah you do have
problems yeah I'm usually surprised at
how many stimulants and [__] you've
talked about using is insane to me oh
yeah it's actually impressive how about
like veneers man just like replace them
all you know what I'm saying I thought
about it you ever looked at how much the
veneers are Ben oh there well it depends
on where you are man like go somewhere
that's what I'm saying you get some
cheap assets I'm not trying to go to
Tijuana
do they shave down your teeth and [__]
you can get you can get them I can I'll
hook you up I don't have them but I know
I know places to do because I had looked
into doing it and then I was like I feel
like I get roasted though if I show up
myself
don't do it you are 100 getting Rose for
that but who cares but also you get
roasted but also your boys
man you should totally do it I just show
up and don't say anything I just gotta
set a [__] not the bad [__]
everyone's talking [__] yeah like Matt
Dylan from uh [__]
Something About Mary yeah
hilarious Man Tony's kind of kid he's
getting [__] up right now that oh
that's a cut that's nasty
he had that I know you guys were that
triangle that he kind of almost yeah was
trying to work on but now it's just it's
Bobby's guard's pretty nasty with the
elbows and his rubber God I don't know
at his age but how old is he 36 39 I
think he's like 39 or 39 yeah I think I
think Bobby Green's 36 and uh Tony's
third now but in fighter years it's like
a dog so yeah
is it do you think it's because of the
stress well the white cut but obviously
he's taking a lot of damage like the
Justin gaichi fight he took all the
damage yeah that one changed it man and
he's a he's a it's a 39. throw Sam Tony
throw sand
I was tired
because this is his last fight I think
no matter what UFC's not gonna keep
doing it no I think I I don't think he's
gonna retire because he strikes me as
one of those guys like a BJ Penn who's
Just Gonna Keep heartbreaking exactly
um but that's what makes him that's what
made him so good yeah I mean do Penn I
mean he would go up what he was 170
champ [__] as well or some [__] like
that yeah I mean dude Penn fought at
heavyweight
at light heavyweight on the Rock in
Hawaii that's why he's the goat
uh no I mean hey Ferguson wants to get
into influencer boxing you know what I'm
saying yeah
Jake Paul Jake Paul's looking right now
I'm like yeah I got it Jake Paul's out
eat his lunch dog
listen Ferguson did drop Bobby green
that power is still there boys he's
still got this
is a wild they're both getting a little
tired too yeah and it's wild so and Tony
flourishes in Wild so we'll see he just
doesn't have the speed he doesn't have
the the the athleticism
let's go this is dangerous right here
though for him man
because Bobby fought Drew Dover he
fought over he recently fought Jared
Gordon and that ended because of a head
butt yeah that's awkward Bobby was
having kind of like middle of the road
first round ducks in and just Jared
Gordon yeah and it was rightfully so
yeah and I feel bad flash is like one of
the nicest [__] he's got such
an amazing story oh I know such a good
dude and I feel bad for Paul Felder
because Paul was cage shot he's buddies
he was so mad he was so mad he's like
he's like what the [__] and I'm like
Paul I feel you yeah you know what I
mean
so who knew Bobby's fight against Drew
Dover was tough Judo was a [__]
I've been watching Judo because he came
up in the same circuit as me so I've
known about Drew Dover for a hot second
dude he's always had like that Crimson
Chain man no dude he's always he's the
most beautiful man in the
ufcs
huge I'll say this man when he fought
for bullet for both one but boys
like those are my guys so when he fought
mad it was a tough tough conflict of
interest and you know I told ma'am like
do not get in a brawl with this cat
usually and Matt was like yeah I'm gonna
do it
how do you think this ends right now
well it's tough because I think it's 1-1
because Ferguson knocked him down it was
really competitive first round so I give
it to Tony second round you saw Bobby
green did so third round I think it's up
for grabs fellas look for grabs yeah
I'll give you that
I could see somebody getting finished
they're getting a little wild here
especially Tony really wild get up get
up and Bobby he's still explosive so
it's trouble when you're playing that
game both guys have power yeah I mean
like each dude is a a missile if they
connect
but I don't like that man no that's what
Gage is gonna be doing he's gonna be
focused on the leg kicks and it's gonna
open up everything upstairs yeah I got
Corey in that yeah do you yeah Grapevine
Louisiana by KO lock it up you want to
make a side view yes but how much you
talking boys
[Laughter]
let's do it
I'm down for a bet yeah me too Doug let
me think about it for a sec all right
nice if you come up Brad if you come up
with a reasonable number I might be able
to hop in on this one I'm a poor yeah
bro yeah
you know what the dicey one too is uh uh
pierra and uh uh yawn because my my
heart goes without yeah my heart's with
Alex my head's like dude take [__]
yawn I've seen this story before man
yeah
knows what to do and that left hook is
dangerous but like Alex was flatlined
three months ago [__] you know what I'm
saying and Yan hits like a truck so I
got I got blue hole but you're not cool
man
damn I wanna
so I mean not on this fight right now
but I'm just I don't know why I'm
thinking about Jon Jones maybe that's a
little weird but that's not weird dude
yeah we we talked about this you know
it's funny sometimes it's funny you know
we talk about like UFC stuff and you
guys how you talk about like this guy's
handsome it reminds me of the
bodybuilding Community because it's like
a little sus yeah this guy's jacked yeah
his glutes are really good and then
finally so then you guys snap out of the
trance and you're like wait a second
what the [__] your boy's like hey man
that's a dude yeah
you're like whoa it's pretty funny
anyways I was I'm curious and I asked
you this on my pod
um is there anyone he fights after John
yeah the word is he retires at my Square
Garden after beats eBay because I don't
think he's gonna wait around for an
aspin all I don't think he's waiting
around for a pavlovich it just doesn't
do much for him palette's a [__]
dude watch when I was a [__] but
for John it's like I'm good I can retire
my home state holy [__] after being
Stipe he's done it all has money yeah I
mean you go down legit go Jon Jones does
not want anything to do with Sergey
pavlovich Tom aspinall
um and I here's the problem it's like
stop there but keep going well I so I'm
one of the biggest Curtis blades fans
That's My Boy Earth Razer blades is the
dog but he takes these fights with power
punchers and decides to just box and I'm
like Curtis he tried to take down Sergey
early on didn't work out it was a bad
shot from far out that's what I'm saying
um and and I feel like Curtis blades is
always right here right here yes the one
to get over the hump he loses it's in
ghanu twice it's Derek Lewis once
he traded my old teams he knows I love
the [__] him it might be here yeah
because he does everything right that's
that one to get him to the dance boom
dude I'll say this though I think Curtis
blades [__] up Jon Jones that's my
heart right now right now I'm at Curtis
plays because he's a horrible matchup
for him but dude best in the world I
don't think anybody be John's I think I
think though who has the best chance is
Aspen all right give him two more fights
like I think he starts to serve God I
think he starches pavlovich I think he
drags Pavlich to the third or fourth
round
tough one I don't think so really no I
think I think that's when I was so much
more athletic and talented than those
boys because Pavlich remember he's been
beat before over in Beetle that was
2018. for sure five years developed and
he starts induced in the first round
astronaut can avoid that big Power Punch
get him into the second third fourth
that's one has all the tools that's
right that's a great point he just trip
he tripped I couldn't tell I think it
was a trip wow we got a Tony Romo
iron
you're like go go there it is 0.5 speed
baby he's on slow motion oh [__] but
this is bad it's a horrible way to end
the round yeah
um what about the women's divisions
let's see Alexa Grosso and uh chefchenko
that'd be a bang over rematch I'm not
sure if it's uh is that boat for
September 16th I thought it was is it
wayle and uh Grasso
oh
yo he's a Savage he's a Savage
you saw him fight that he was like [__]
it I'm going to sleep damn [__] big one
for Bobby I think the UFC Cuts Tony
three fights in a row that he's been
finished that's depressing yeah if
you're a vintage Tony fan no okay but
that was like a good Tony man like he
was all right in there it was
competitive competitive dude here's okay
here's what's crazy about it though it's
like you look at the Charles Olvera the
beniel Darius fights he was not tapping
at all in those spots and he's still not
tapping yeah that [__] is a
Savage yeah he just oh why do we got his
waking up see how many losses like
that's six right [__] is that six in a
row that's five six six that's the Nate
that was a rough one the Chandler one he
looked all right dude's decision but
let's be fair here those are really
great Fighters
champion champion
number two like the UFC was like oh
you're having problems at home that's
terrible here's [__] just engaging
here's Charles Oliveira like oh really
something figured it out at home cool
here's Darius here's Michael Channel
here's Dave Diaz man you're on a five
fight losing skin here's [__] Bobby
green like he's fought the best of the
best
[__] man remember this that one yeah
he really went out you [__] it yeah if
that's if that's the last we see at Tony
Ferguson
amen what a career yeah for sure some
eternal life Doug right that's just your
signature move yeah would that be dope
that was a I think it's dope I'll
consider I'll talk with the team yeah on
top of my team let me get back to you
damn Bobby green I mean here's the thing
like again Bobby green fantastic fighter
well-earned Victory he's fought the best
too islamicacho he's not a tough he's
only won two out of his last four dog
last second fight Drew Dover nightmare
he was he was beating drover I mean he
was like touching him dober's face was
lacerated but he got that he got he got
that he got [__] phone booth fight
and you use not want to play that with
judoma no you remember that fight with
Raphael Alvis Rapha was like emoting and
then he got cut up oh
that's the worst cut that the UFC's ever
made in my opinion like that guy is one
of the most fun lightweights never gets
us do God I love I just I always say we
can never hear the audio isn't that a
bummer I want to hear a joke you have
seen some haters man the kick is off
yeah I also get it though yeah can't be
streaming their stuff
I'm curious it looks like Tony's not I
mean he's not taking the gloves off yet
I doubt he would again if that guy
retires if I'm his coach I'm like can I
just uh yeah I throw him on the ground
you're picking him up okay
get him now no no I'm not retired yes
you are I'm on the rematch
what a tough [__] ending man if only
Tony had a little happy hippo listen
Happy Hippos Taffy on sale this weekend
they're running a buy one get one 50 off
these are a fan favorite one of their
most popular items I love them also
their new two ounce energy shots that's
what your boy uses before every freaking
show I do it's back in stock the best
tasting option in the industry that's
Happy Hippo they have freaking buy one
get one fifty percent off also use promo
code thick 23 you get 20 off for life at
happy people.com enjoy
speaking of money
I thought about it uh with Main Event
can you talk about Main Event co-main
Event Main Event main event gaichi
gaichi Victoria
I'm saying geishi okay I'll take poorier
the diamond
and uh this hot sauce in there dude it's
good hot sauce last night I feel like
last time we I don't know I think we did
five so I think we gotta double it
10 G yeah well I mean listen I know I
know you're a car guy I know you're a
car guy you got some you have some nice
jumped in the whip the other day yes you
didn't think you'd fit I had no idea
man I'm confident about this though all
right I'm confident about it all right
you really believe poorier yes
why do you believe geichi tell me how he
beats Poirier
was losing on on the cards a little bit
and also with the leg kicks he literally
was not I looked I watched that fight
two days ago I looked at the scorecards
it was heavily emporia's favor the only
thing gagey had was the leg kicks he was
getting countered he was getting ripped
him was on side going to that fourth and
he had the iPhone okay the fourth round
it was gate she was kind of taken over
yes into that fourth round and they got
clocked immediately Poirier timed that
leg kick in round one he was launching
that left straight I'll be honest round
one [__] all that I saw a clip
Jorge was talking about like he you know
beating bigger guys is easy and that
just kind of pissed me off personally
that's a 260 mindset that's a 260
mindset on 260 by the list also changes
fighting style according to him and
Trevor Whitman since last time he's
fighting smarter which I think it's his
strength of schedule it allows him to
fight smart and get wins I don't know if
James Vick Edson Barboza Donald Cerrone
were the three fights
all older exactly and he got first round
caves in all of them because again it's
easier competition so what do you want
Brad what do you want shoot dog you want
the 10 yeah just flat cash out yeah all
right or like whatever you can cash me
cash me I don't have 10 G's cash what I
look like come on it looks like Steve
Jobs done yeah whatever
okay no going back on that nope you got
it okay now I'll be stressed out the
entire night
I'm so intense I'm gonna give Shob five
dollars
it'll be ten thousand and five dollars
yeah there you go
she's a monster
right oh
not what I expected Amanda lamosh
a why not run the remastering that's a
good fight then you got uh Tatiana and
uh homegirl
Al Joe O'Malley who do you got in that
one man Sterling or Sean
that's tough they're both my guys I hate
making picks yeah yeah
you just gone Josh
um Montana O'Malley still who you got
it's tough because Sean's an Arizona boy
I have such a soft spot in my heart for
him but I think aljo's been counted out
so many times before it's just so weird
[__] it up
and then I'm gonna go interview Sean
before
yeah that's dope Tim Welch is like the
goat dude Tim's awesome we're gonna talk
about street fights [__] off
there's a UFC fighter named Roger worth
and he was a big deal at the time when
this street fight happened so he's in
Austin Texas okay he's leaving a bar and
this guy he like hits oh this is a
street fight oh I saw this and this
guy's a he's a he's a lineman for
University of Texas and he gets Molly
[__] and this is a street fight now Roger
worked a fight at 155. the guy he's
fighting is so much better he throws a
girl on the ground you'll see what
Huerta always wear beanie or backwards
uh newspaper boy hat don't let him fool
you Dime Piece too ICE train with Dime
Piece
he used to date the girl from uh
backwards that's weird the hot redhead
from that it's got a tiny bill
it looks like a like Scarlett Johansson
nope hey what is this
oh That 70s Show yeah that 70 show he
used to date her he was in our camp used
to bring her to the camp we're like oh
he took his shirt off he was dating
then Roger word uh it's hard this video
dude who filmed this on like a
Blackberry dude
oh yeah [__] dude where did Roger go
what the [__] I feel like I'm looking
for aliens
dude it's the only example we have oh
someone's dead someone's job
look he's dead there's a video of
angling like jumps up like this
like a Superman like Troy
boom knocks him out handsome as [__]
Roger I like how the angle he is the
guy's already done the guy in a span of
10 seconds is unconscious on the floor
that's almost scarier but the guy he was
fighting was probably like you know 180.
yeah one two six I think it's probably
not
the guy was fighting might have been 260
Brad I don't know oh man I can't wait to
see Sean fight man that's a great fight
Santa Hagen and Rob font I'm doing a
fight command with Rogan next Saturday
for that dude short notice short notice
for Rob yeah I don't know if I like that
one for him because he was supposed to
fight song that's a great fight he's a
[__] how gangster said Hagen to
fight to fight [__] homeboy uh nobody
wanted to fight um yeah yeah it's gonna
be a banger man I like core I think he's
one of the best bands in weights and
again that fight with aljo where
Sterling choked him out in 90 seconds
dude in the office age like wine man
that's sauvignon blanc right there type
[__] my boy Billy corn tillos on that
card it's called Billy Billy but um
Corey's a Savage too because he was on
here I'm like why would you want to
fight [__] no Margaret Madoff he's
like because when I'm champ like if I
can't beat him I don't deserve to be
champ I'm gonna fight everybody before
I'm champ so I know I'm the actual
baddest man on the planet fear point to
you that's a chant mindset yeah the
money fight would be just get to the
belt and then worry about that other
kick and be selected yeah yeah but
that's what Brad does man yeah
yeah he's got a chance mindset baby I
gotta have it man dude people have
sliding my DMs and be like dude I'll
tell Brad I'll fight him like no no you
don't understand no you're not a
professional dude this only worked yeah
exactly
and I'll respond back but I want to be
like Brad will [__] you up how about
that dude I'll say this this morning I
was looking at a couple Bradley Martin
Clips oh my God I did my research
podcast Loosely no it was like you
grappling some random [__] in
like a scary some [__] you get a nice
kicked in the face by a hot chick and
didn't even Flinch I don't think I saw
that clip oh man but you had a nice you
somebody was like they went in on a
single and you just [__] lifted him
up oh that's Steve was it Steve no that
was my buddy uh Jordan
yeah
but whatever you know it's just the
reality he was a third degree black belt
under Enzo Gracie but whatever you know
but who cares but I think I will say
this I think as much as people like give
you [__] about it I
oh yeah just not not at the UFC level
you know what I'm saying you shop for
them not in the UFC you know on a street
yeah well there's UFC levels on the
street 260 dog keep it going man it's
too funny
oh it's honestly just I get so much
enjoyment I didn't honestly didn't think
it would go that crazy I mean it did
yeah then it did yeah and then like you
once you see how many people actually
really pisses them off you're like oh
this is reaching a bunch of new people
yeah who like [__] this guy I didn't
think it was a when you said I'm like
yeah he says you [__] around there bro
my show like it's barely [__] around
to be honest with Haney yeah he probably
[__] oh you small dude he gets in
close he's [__] huge didn't think of
it then we talked about it was a show
and then my brother was like okay that
clip of you and Bradley and you talking
about Mighty Mouse it's at three million
views I'm like what bro not just that
clip like on Tick Tock there's like it's
like millions and millions yeah tons of
people I think I do lessons on Twitter
it's like nine million views it's all I
see on Tick Tock is the Logan Paul [__]
or Bradley [__] challenging random
people to street fight I gotta make that
a series you need to make merch you
gotta I got a mute Bradley
or all I see is 260. all I see is Reds
everyone can relate to that all I see is
red and all I see is red no that's
really what happened all I see is red
bro yeah straight up that actually
happens that's going to sell like did
you see red yeah it's like imagine like
the Predator you ever look you see
everything yeah he sees like the shades
like he has like it's like blue and
green I just read
yeah
[__] nothing yeah yeah you and Stevie
Wonder bro it's just like I can't see
it's all red
I don't know what's gonna happen man
yeah that's too funny man I love it I
love the internet man it's a great place
Derek loose fighting delima here uh I
think they put Derek Lewis on purpose in
Salt Lake City at high altitude because
like [__] you got one round get it done
not even around you got two minutes bro
you've got 120 seconds two minutes it's
a rough dude enjoy those two minutes
with Derrick Lewis going Full Throttle
I'm gonna give you the numbers okay
between these two guys they have 23
first round finishes I do not anticipate
this getting out of the first round hold
up if he gets out of the first round
this can be disaster it's gonna be a
horrible fight
Elon and Zuckerberg I got Marcos because
I think I got Derek Lewis five dollars
uh yeah that's a big bet for me
I'll do it
no I like Derek but again like he's on a
tough skid I will say this though kind
of like Tony he's fought some really
good names Sergey Spivak
um I think he fought zero gone from the
interim belt and that was Derek's been
on a tough tough Bliss but that's why he
was like what number three in the world
was where it went tough one yeah yeah he
fought him in his coach looks like Super
Mario I watched that fight Nissan they
love this [__] because he's from
Texas he's the hometown dude his
Instagram before he got taken out for
the haters reported he was at like six
million [__] people he's a superstar
and I'll say this Marcos or Jerry De
Lima doesn't have like huge big name
wins he I think submitted Andre olowsky
he used to fight at 205 bro smaller
[__] but again like he's Marco
says a dog like that's a clubber 205.
not the other guy the other guy dude big
[__] in there yeah he used to
fight at 205. yeah
whoa
God damn
it's Wild by Derek Lewis game over who
you are but it's like is he gonna fire
back I feel like this version of Derek
Lewis is a guy who doesn't like taking
shots but he knows he has two minutes
and he's shredded now honestly I
shredded
for him sure whoa it was like dude it
was like the the six pack
did you hear what it usually looks like
he looks a little slim a little leaner I
love watching that big guy that's a
human pistachio right there man that guy
looks like the rock if he only had seven
bucks still damn
close [__]
I think again now here's here's the
other thing though Derek is the all-time
KO leader it's hard to bet against him
that's an amazing stats especially when
this guy's gonna take chances and open
up the trade bro all-time KO leader a
wild wild prediction right here first 40
seconds big knockout Derry Lewis dude I
wouldn't be shocked it's not that one
first 40 seconds okay a hot 38.
38 a clean 38. do I have you oh look
260. okay yeah big boys
oh you got dilemma
yes
he's on attack again minus 210.
the betting Republic those are good bets
the gambling Republic is behind me yeah
they are I get the dog here should be
noted dude
how about we got 10 G's on the main
event
I'm trying to have fun at his [__]
bananas that you did that I feel good
about that do you yeah you shouldn't I
feel great that's one Tick Tock video
for Bradley challenging [__] hey
you'll make it back on The Tick Tock
Snapchat two days on Snapchat
I'm about to Snapchat this dick
Whoa man
I'm excited I'm surprised he's a
favorite he's on a terror man he's not
he's like a four or five fight win
streak or some [__] like that uh and
again peanuts such a higher level and
then especially there's use some main
events this dude's never been on a main
card on Pay-per-view
it's the nature of the biz if somebody's
on the decline and somebody's coming up
that's what they did you know what I
mean
I'm excited so this dude beat Andre
olowsky submission
um and again I mean he's got you beat
Ben Rothwell bait Ben Rothwell yeah that
was an amazing like 40 second knockout
remarkable she's been you're all right
in my book
um and again I think I think Marcos has
got 15 first round finishes Derek's got
eight first round Kos I think those are
the the numbers on it uh yeah look at
that um that's a handsome young lady
look at him just [__] that's a dude
oh that's a [__] bro right no no dude
you ever been to Salt Lake
BYU Casey you went to Salt Lake guys and
girls at BYU we're like the U I'm like
that's Miami
45 seconds
that dude looks like a baby that's like
that take the heavy under right there
yeah 45. come on Marcos one punch baby
it's about to go down boom Oh
foreign
pounds filthy if he don't get ankle oh
[__] oh Mount this one's over oh damn my
five dollars man no he's moving oh my
god dude don't get yourself out here
Derek big boys holy [__] dude did he do
a flying [__] knee yeah get out of
there that's game yeah
wow what was the time on that
no seriously what a great win I really
want to know that's crazy it had him as
a dog man he's been some big fights bro
dude yeah and he's back against the wall
and he's lost weight which come on Daddy
what's the time chat what's the time
talk to me wow Chad let me know you
can't hate that I mean listen you're
saying no Chad as in the chat because
they're good this card could like result
in any way shape or form but a Derrick
Lewis first round knockout I'll tell you
I'll take it 35 seconds oh you're close
you're wrong you're close though dude
wrong I'm bathroom I'm breaking it I'm
breaking the seal
you got this done make sure you get the
key dog yeah
let's go in the sink like I do damn
I saw that one coming in I guess he
called it you called it it's not a hard
production wall one round yeah it's a
bad that's elevation I was these are
better than the night my boy puts the
big money on that was my go-to bet Derek
Lewis
Todd did he even get him with the knee
or was it just like uh
they need to slow it down here we go
this guy's I guess gonna be so fun yeah
Salt Lake what am I doing oh my god oh
how do you get that knee man he really
clipped them to London wow
yeah he did not see that one coming
and then his ground pound is some of the
nasty damn bro
you call it brother yeah that was dope
wow that's not yeah you definitely don't
want to get mounted by this one
I'm not trying to get mounted by hey man
that's uh with three finishes on the
main main card oh three for three you
know what that means I'm I'm I got some
here's my worry about the main event
because it was almost five of the year
in 2018 there's all these like huge like
expectations it's when you put too much
expectations on a fight like Francis
ingano Derek Lewis it sometimes it can
hurt your feelings
I mean for the fighters or just for the
fight It's just tough to live up to but
with Poirier and gaichi gaichi's never
been a boring fight neither has pory for
that matter I think party's gonna
grapple more
what round I think I think uh poor a
submits him in the third or fourth round
I can't wait to win that money man
that's all I'm thinking about it feels
good
it's always good taking that like not
from like sports betting but like from a
friend yeah you know because you can
watch me spend it I'm also excited dude
yeah that's the best part
I'll just think like a few of your car
payments I'll be like yeah yeah
it's mine thanks Doug
it's cool
so you've been training your kid yeah
he loves it I gotta bring him to I gotta
go I haven't been to the zoo yeah I come
I now do I saw some funny comments there
like who wins in the street fighters
you're just a street fighter now
apparently you're [__] Kimbo Slice
now dude oh man
like partially worried tell me how to do
that all right fine just for you guys
yeah no one's gonna see it oh yeah my
bad yeah no you're fine
yeah Tiger's in the gym today hitting
mitts and then he has baseball tryouts
in two weeks
that's all come down too my whole
Summer's been just dedicated to him
[__] making this baseball team if he
doesn't I'm gonna fail as a father nah
so so and he won't get snacks for a week
but you want like do you have a
obviously I think you want to play
baseball it sounds like he wants to play
baseball okay what if he wanted to do
this no no way nope
too tough of a gig juice isn't worth the
squeeze for every Conor McGregor there's
a million [__] people working at UFC
boxing I see
yeah
also tough kids don't come out of
Calabasas
damn it's real
it is what it is like like Tyson says
boxing comes from the gutters yeah
UFC fighting comes from the streets
streets see street fights street fights
yeah Street Fighter dog yeah do you do
some dope merch with like the street
fighter font and [__] oh yeah you're
right that old school Street Fighter fun
that's right lit we did that for final
Merchant yeah Street Fighter fighting
the kid
I should release it I should release a
shirt yeah trust me I see red bro
who'd you say is the mo okay I guess
it's Conor the most impactful person
fighter in the UFC well as far as
business-wise and like like taken to
another level be Connor but then there's
also the argue there's like Conor
there's Rhonda Pierce Gracie pure
fighting just fighting just fighting
as far ah [__] it stopped the Henderson
Silva GSP probably GSP I think yeah I
think a GSP and I'm not even as versed
in this [__] as you are obviously just
probably a little bit better man
probably a little better
when you go to the gym or people like
man this is crazy bro we think you would
[__] up [__] I'm not gonna lie or
whatever no not like your boys no but
there there are there has been random
people who've come up to me and be like
like I was eating at a Mexican
restaurant and some dude came up was
like yo I watch your power with Nate I
think he would [__] him up I don't know
dude I appreciate it I appreciate the
support man yeah I love the love you get
the real ones yeah um but yeah but then
they're just like yeah I watch the pot I
appreciate it blah blah it's nice that's
nice but I have I have got comments like
that yeah yeah of course
especially right now now it's like
anywhere I go I hear it
it's pretty funny
Brad I got a question for you LeAnn
Rimes I've seen her in a hot second yeah
why is he there hold on
Brad who do you think would win oh I
know that girl what the hell my Rubino
Silva that no let me show them with that
fighter oh really wow I also know that
guy too
what the hell there he is you can't have
a BMF title without him there I think
Kevin Gaston was in the background one
of those shots yeah the last one
he's a Arizona boy yeah yeah yeah yeah
dude he's the nicest [__] uh
Kane's at Arizona boy isn't he he went
to ASU
Kane went to ASU I think he's from
California I think he's more caliber oh
you're right yeah you're right yeah he
is
he's an ASU cat yeah dude are those ASU
wrestlers are built different man I'll
tell you what like [__] yeah the four
years I was there it was the I would say
in terms of most impressive like sports
program that we had like our football
team wasn't really the best our
basketball team is never the best your
baseball is good right baseball's pretty
okay yeah baseball is all right but then
wrestling's off the charts Ryan Bader
Kane
um [__] I'm trying to think of some of
the guys right now CB dollarway so he's
a dog
go ahead
Brad do you think I'd be industry if I
come on ah goes lay up baby bro
how much do you wear hmm
260 bro come on
same as you Doug James
[Music]
five days notice oh [__] did you get
ankle locked or knee box I got subbed in
13 seconds that's usually how these
things go that's what we're about it I
was about it man they were like yo you
know don't be a [__] show up and I was
like I'll [__] be there I flowed
Philly and um they [__] up my walkout
first of all well I wanted to Pour Some
Sugar On Me by Def Leppard and they
played this like [__] slowed down
Reverb remix and I'm like I eat it's so
just some young kid [__] up straight
up so I come out and then he throws a
flying triangle at me I defend it
beautifully and then gets subbed
immediately after 13 seconds
but you didn't get like roasted for that
like most people were like now it's more
respect yeah I was like you showed up
and I was like yeah a lot of people in
the MMA space like especially like the
you know the journalists and [__] like
that guys like me were like oh this is
badass no matter what happens well I
think dude I think anyone who wants to
die that's what we met I was like dude
it's dope you're doing exactly yeah if
you write about MMA or you
um want to be considered a journalist in
the space you should do [__] like that
like you should try and compete you
should try and maybe do some grappling
competitions because it's credibility
and maybe maybe you're gonna win maybe
you're gonna lose but like I feel like
everything go through the process though
exactly like there's just more respect
um I will say I got a rematch not a
rematch I got another fight booked in
December it's play-by-play I'm not gonna
say who was a big play-by-play big name
I can't say much all right big
commentator thankfully not a [__]
black belt oh he's a big commentator
yeah you're gonna fight another
commentator yeah I'm like that's more
even yeah you don't do a high level I
don't want Brad Bolton again man that
[__] I agree with what you said
though like having having skin in the
game and knowing you also get more
respect from the fighter you're way more
connected to it too it's like exactly
that's why I have so many street fights
that's why I'm undefeated in street
fights when is the last street fight
you've been in Brad oh man I don't know
if I could I guess I could tell this
story it wasn't even a street fight I
just I he just shot a guy yeah I cold
caught some lady no no
I literally I San Francisco because
she's Chinese
like you're that guy I've been in San
Francisco in years yeah I've been there
they won't see me there there's no
security table no it wasn't a fight I
literally I just yeah you just knocked
something I was it was gone he was
talking to you I was like try something
okay I'm going to yeah all I see is red
I didn't see red no I just was like bang
oh that's a difference and he was out
yeah when you're seeing clear that was a
while ago uh it's time ago
it was a time ago you mean last Tuesday
they like to make like Steve made a joke
it's like it was in Starbucks like I
gave me the wrong order so I just
[__] punched him in the face no but
it was it was a few years back yeah dude
why okay this is like who's street
fights you know what I'm saying like
like for you to do it with like Nate I
get it but like who straight up street
fights it's insane bro that's the most
dangerous especially at your level then
you can just look you up like I'm gonna
Sue this dude yeah it's the most
dangerous thing anyways like someone
could pull a gun you're [__] or they
hit their head they're screwed yeah yeah
why okay so question why back in the day
was Steve always like Brad Martin sold
me drugs how the [__] did that start
it was a joke uh tell the real story oh
okay that's thick boy exclusive this is
a real this is I've actually I don't
think I've ever oh damn I don't know if
I could really admit this basically at
one point in my life I I needed money
and I and I did things that I should
have done for money
for money at one point and he knew that
so Steve is Steve's the kind of person
like he'll make jokes and like kind of
like dance that line yeah so because he
knew that one piece of information he
like ran with it and it just stuck it
was funny so now like even taking your
comments people like oh you sell drugs
still it's been years since that joke
yeah well it's hilarious I imagine I
imagine why don't you make merch well
they did they made millions and millions
of dollars from merch I made none of it
oh well that's not cool I think I don't
know
Steve made millions of dollars hey Steve
yeah bro
come on I came up with it like no I sold
the drugs dude how are you benefiting
off me the shirt literally said Bradley
Martin sold me drugs
you're a smart business dude what are
you doing honestly you sold drugs dude I
mean I'll be fair like it was it was
it's so much fun making the content with
Steve when we were able to do it
such a synergistic thing where it's like
but also give him 10 yeah I hear you
yeah and and I eventually asked for that
and then it's like oh we're not really
doing merch anymore
no we stopped selling those he's like oh
we discontinued that man no no I know
but you sold 10 million of them yeah
yeah so we spent it nah it's cool though
it's cool but but that joke literally
came from like a like a tiny truth
that's funny and then it just you were
selling like hardcore stuff or no no no
like performance enhancing stuff yes yes
that makes sense that checks out yeah
could you imagine Bradley Martin is like
your coke dealer holy [__] you're huge
dude yeah whoa dude read that don't ever
don't say that but read that no
that's pretty funny no because that was
one of the videos that popped up between
the grappling stuff was the the Bradley
Martin sold me choice and I was like
what the [__]
yeah it was a he's just crazy Steve's
[__] crazy yeah he's crazy white okay
so he's [__] crazy the sex is crazy I
know I know you know what's funny this
text I'll never I'll never explain it
but like uh that happened where I was
also there once No One's Gonna
understand the context of this so I had
to be like yo who got a dip
yeah that could get dicey for him if uh
like yeah he's almost filming yeah
yeah bro they're like what the [__] is
he talking about sorry just yeah dude
don't even worry about it legit could
not say what it is never say please tell
me what it is but no like that's like
Steve's [__] crazy crazy dude I mean
any [__] person crazy years ago
watching him smoke like hundreds of
cigarettes in a video or like slugging
down so many beers like yeah there was a
video I saw him he with David dobrik
um back when David was still doing like
YouTube videos and not only Snapchat and
Steve had this like weed vacuum thing
like where they like lit a ton of weed
and he just like sucked they were in
yeah they sucked it in they were in a
damn like garage and like even going
into film because I was out there for
the bit because secondhand high like
instantly everyone in there guys so much
it was it was insane they kicked him off
YouTube right so he's only on Rumble
he's on Rumble
um he's coming this week we're going to
film some like short form content for
like Twitter and Instagram and stuff
but um yeah he can't post at all
is he the only guy kicked off YouTube
yeah and it's weird because
because this stuff was like he did like
a gambling site yeah there's a bunch of
weird [__] that said like that's what it
sounds like but then he told me he goes
I think Schultz was talking about he's
like yeah and then I got a YouTube the
lady works at YouTube's number I harass
her and talk [__] to her yeah that's
probably what's doing it I don't know
the details but I know it's it's a weird
he says I'm not out in that yeah he's
like yeah and then I found out one of
the heads at YouTube I got her cell
phone every so time time I'll get a
little drunk and just spit off a hard
Tax Center yeah he's like yo like she's
like no never dude you're never good
enough I want him to come back so bad
it's just it's a weird thing because
like he doesn't need to yeah he doesn't
need to no but it's like for me if he
did something that was like because the
gambling thing's like so everyone does
it or everyone promoting it in different
ways and it's like all of all these
other platforms so for that to be his
reason is weird because it's like you
know something else going on there yeah
because as a Creator it's like if he did
some weird [__] and then like where he'd
be canceled in a real way where like you
know if it was some like Logan Paul in
the suicide forest like they allowed him
come back after he paid his dues right
so like if Steve did some [__] that was
out actually like really I guess just my
moral compass super [__] up which
gambling because it's it's everywhere
already it's not that crazy [__] up so
it's hard for me to be like cool with it
because I'm like I want to film with him
but like but if you put him on your
channel because he can't oh wow like he
can't be honestly he can't be on no she
can't be on any channels that's the
[__] up part is like oh there's a lot
more going on with us that's what I'm
saying like you know that's a personal
Vendetta I would love if he can just be
in my content he doesn't have to promote
gambling or anything wrong just like
let's because I would work out with him
all the time and even if you don't say
like Steve's in the video if they if
just his image shows his voice his face
everything damn he's completely [__]
off YouTube that's ridiculous and that's
what sucks because like the first guy in
history bro that's the thing is like if
it was some because like because there's
some vile [__] on there man right like
if he did some real [__] up [__] then
like everyone be like yo we're not
really filming with you so it's a weird
cause I'll go please a good dude yeah
great dude great person super Heart of
Gold so it's like thank God he doesn't
have to worry about it because he's with
Rumble he does his thing crushes it yeah
crushes it so we're gonna try and do
some short for himself which will be it
should be entertaining for Snapchat guys
Snapchat like Twitter Instagram [__]
yeah I'm curious so the uh the milk pod
yeah I saw someone where you were like
oh they just didn't ask me back yes why
yeah why because you were on for years
like for years not for years I was not
for years no I was unfair I don't even
know how many episodes but maybe about a
year he was like I was on for 11 months
and three weeks and well you said years
and then something happened no it's just
like they just stopped inviting me I was
never like a host host and then they
just stopped inviting me on
I don't get that schultzie knows you
talk to Schultz I didn't ask him about
it specifically I mean yeah Schultz had
a tough one I know he I know I think he
probably wanted me on that pod yeah he
probably should have been there yeah
I went and did his pod like you know wow
a year prior to that and it was amazing
one like it was such a good vibe one of
the best Vibes I've ever had on Chelsea
won the best in podcasts he's got well
he's got a great crew too as well you
know what I mean he's good at everything
yeah that was a really fun time but yeah
it's like I mean I'd love to do it but
it's like I'm not you know did you do
you not talk to him at all anymore I
talked to him I talked to mostly steiny
but not and he doesn't say anything
can't you ask him but he's kind of like
yo I want to get you back on and I'm
like well like do it do it yeah do it if
you want to do it so interesting it's
not my you know you know it's like
someone else's thing yeah yeah
that's fair I just thought I thought I
was like no you're feeling better hurt
bro it's whatever nah yeah well
especially like how much you're
balancing it's like all right you know
if you don't want me whatever yeah
that's I thought it was a little weird
I'm like Bradley I guess I I
misunderstood how long you're on the Pod
I thought you were like more of a staple
on it you know what I'm saying yeah did
you like the episodes I was on [__] man
I'll tell you what I don't think I
listened to a single one
no I would pop in here and there but no
I'll tell you this [__] your turtleneck
you know what now that's a little word
okay I'll say this though the clips that
I saw mostly on Five Dollar Bank go [__]
yourself
you can make a ten we can make a ten no
but I would see you like on the clips
and [__] yeah you know what I mean and
so I'm like oh I guess I thought I
thought that there was more of a staple
yeah yeah is what it is man I can't wait
for this fight this is a pick and fight
former like heavyweight champion versus
the former middleweight champion
then and what's cool about this is yawn
will play in the stand-up game and Alex
Pierre is a [__] world champion
kickboxer knocked out Izzy his last
fight he got knocked out by Izzy Brad so
this is a big fight I'll say this though
like the minus 110 odds on this are
interesting because yambohovich dealt
with adesanya dude so well uh a couple
years back that's for those first rounds
weren't you know first rounds were
competitive but Jan outlanded him every
single round it's not like Jan was
washed in the stripes versus Izzy yamboo
which was piecing him up and then
checking once he got him down I'm just
curious because Alex is a little
different than Izzy like and he's big
that left that left Hook's a [__]
Oppenheimer nuke yeah and I wonder how
long uh Jan's gonna play with it because
John will play with that stand up with
him and I wonder how long he's engaged
before you know dude if yon dies I'm
gonna be so sad I'm gonna be really
[__] big I got the Brazilian 100 yeah
oh wow the key shot right away there you
go that's what he should have done oh
that's I found his his entire train Camp
put him on his ass and joke him out but
remember here's the other thing I'll
experience no punk too because yeah
Clover fought on twice twice was it
twice or once but you go you're right
yeah it was it was that again that left
hook Yama stun and then go over got that
rear [__] I wonder if he jumped to
guard here that'd be a nightmare for him
but he he should do it if he thinks he's
gonna get taken down because this is
easy for her to take down here he's
polish he's good
that's smarter younger for the single
not the double I'll say this if is there
a lot of sign it can take you down then
Yan bohovich can [__] make you as
[__] struggling right now though yeah
that is fair
but if they're still dry they're still
dry
if I'm Alex if you feel like you're
gonna take it down I would have jumped
to that guilty and I don't know what Jiu
Jitsu is like
I can't imagine great if you jump Gilly
and then you [__] up boom you're off
your back but my thing is it looks like
well he's doing a good job not getting
taken down here
he needs to get back to the cage yeah
don't go to the middle though you can't
you can't run the pipe further on that
single the pipes already run yeah you
know what I'm saying would you switch to
a double in that scenario if I'm if I'm
uh John John there it's tough because
his hips are turned you can drop down
here you see how when you see how he'll
get his feet close together that's when
he should drop right when right when
Alex moves his left knee towards his
right that's when you drop down recover
beautiful and now Alex is fun this is
the problem with the fight because this
is gonna be a dope oh [__]
oh that's a big boy wow what a turn
around that's a big boy alex was doing
well but that's game damn yeah there's
no way you could do that for three
rounds
there's so many fun matchups for Alex
even if you lose this one there's a lot
of fun matchups you got Johnny Walker no
I mean he's fighting it okay
he's fighting
it's uncomfortable his coach like he
only got 240 left
a nightmare [__] man worst position to
just just weather the storm 240 left and
imagine the cardio at elevation you're
wearing Jan buhovich for two minutes bro
[__] that God
yeah that was because you gotta you'd
figure Alex would assume he'd just jump
in like that so what he been doing Doug
especially that body triangle
that's a tough world to be for Alex
perea but again like that knockout power
bro did you um did you watch their uh
their fights without assigning prayer oh
yeah dude yeah he's got some bombs yeah
he's a [__] beast exactly that's why
I said he wanted to win so much I still
think he's winning it yeah I hope he
does if he can defend if he can defend
this nicely round two might be round two
knockout that's what I'm saying because
remember because it's a lot of uh energy
on yawn with this body lock like that's
a lot of [__] energy to ride a guy
like this
he just needs to protect his neck and
get out for one for a minute 40. yeah he
needs a key control there you go I'll
say this I mean Bradley Martin would
never get in this position he would have
no busted out I would have beat him up
before
dude
over the street fight man as soon as he
started taking his his [__] off okay
you're in the locker room with him he'd
have been in the bathroom
that's the only way I beat one of these
monkeys to be honest with you I mean but
you got you got you got the tactics
going you know what I mean yeah all
right he's doing well here
he just needs to chill out for a minute
if I'm young I let go of that body lock
yeah and try and like swing around a
little bit Yeah because clearly Alex's
first Alex he can turn into him and land
up in guard here
the body looks tough to maneuver oh
that's not good I know he's I mean
John's kind of going for broke a bit
two hands on one
he's still all right yeah this isn't
good
work John yeah yeah I love the change
yeah [__] leather
he's doing well defending it he needs
both no you got to protect oh this truck
oh there we go thank God
I'm impressed by Alex second round
knockout
come on I mean now he knows he can
defend it he's probably gonna let them
hands go he's gonna release the Hound he
has to him he's gotta get some respect
he's gonna release that Oppenheimer on
his [__] face Waits okay did you guys
watch Oppenheimer or Barbie nah man no
you look like a guy who watched Barbie
straight up bro you look like that guy
he went to both but you lost actually
twice Bradley I did yeah I believe you
did you do which one did you like better
if you had to recommend I think I rank
Oppenheimer a bit better because Robert
Downey Jr is exceptional I heard an
Oppenheimer dude he's fine Robert Downey
Jr says the best movie he's ever done
which doesn't shock me I mean
Christopher Nolan's a dog I heard it's
three hours long
it should I'll tell you it should have
been cut down there was a lot of scenes
where I was like ass boring as [__]
um but that's Chris Nolan you know you
gotta ride that out yeah Barbie was
interesting I liked Barbie what is
what's that about so essentially Margot
Robbie discovers the real world and goes
from Barbie land to the real world and
so she's a she's a Barbie that becomes a
real person
how does she become a real person
um rollerblading no she [__] straight
up rollerblades sure way to be RV figure
is rollerblading becomes a human there's
dude well there's always into like a
portal straight up yeah there's kind of
like a roll blank is part of the portal
um but she's stereotyping oh look at the
Alex Bro
bring it
there yeah you know what y'all might be
a little bit tired was that his best
play
I think John's probably like yeah this
guy's grabbing a little bit and I
thought he's gonna he's gonna shoot in
hard here he can do it everywhere now
Alex John's probably a little tired
John's head is so big he's backing up I
mean but Alex is bigger you know so we
really need to show 10-9 yeah no [__] yo
Aaron bronstetter the goat
you throw goat around a little too much
huh yeah everybody's to go okay I like
that I enjoy it too
I like Aaron by the way keto George said
uh was it Crawford drop Spence second
round fight still going on holy [__]
[__] spoiler [__] wait wait I was gonna
watch that after this man
the copper did drop him yeah I picked
bud not a big deal
I'm a big Errol Crawford guy what a dude
dude we're me and my brother in the
boxing gym with my son and some guy goes
bro I gotta know we interrupt I'm like
training my son we're in the middle he's
like dude I hate dinner up I'm like okay
you just gotta know who do you got
tonight you know I'm UFC personally yeah
I'll take pour him answer me a good one
he's like what are you talking about
yeah
he's like Dustin poregas oh what is that
like UFC I'm like yeah he goes no the
[__] boxing fight oh yeah I'm a
boxing gym I was like yeah bud man
I don't like that a dude asking what is
that doesn't pray as tied for most fight
of the nights in UFC history what do you
mean you don't know hardcore like boss
well you don't know it's also like the
biggest nine box in a hot second so I
can kind of understand I guess
you got no it doesn't pour it yeah
otherwise you're a communist dude the
diamonds yeah straight up I stopped
talking to him after that oh John caught
him there bro
he gets clipped though beautiful
out of all the matchups though it's like
such a bad matchup for Alex Pierre like
Stylistics yeah there's so many much the
Yuri fight is fun Jamal hell will be so
much Jamal heals dope but obviously
injury yeah uh you got Johnny Walker
there Anthony Smith will be fun Johnny
Walker Johnny walk I said that since the
job is that a good fight that's an
amazing such a good fight uh but the
thing I feel like if Alex perea breathed
on his chin that kind of became over I
feel you know what I'm saying
yeah dude you're like I want that to
happen there's so much better matches
for Alex Pierre than this yawn fight but
I love it I think they were thinking
former Champion former Champion if
you're gonna get through the division
you can't avoid yawn and magomanov well
imagine fight one of them imagine Alex
starch Dion went on and won the belt
then you do arasania versus perea but
they're both Champions no here he comes
back bro or or even that [__]
think about that fight poster beautiful
you have Alex Pierre in that [__]
like the Brazilian Native American thing
which confuses me you always got the
samurai the long
[Laughter]
oh my god did they wear feathers shout
out to my Brazilian Native Americans bro
yo that's funny oh God Alex is up yo
there oh look at that though that's fire
that's some Paul Craig war paint right
that [__] is intense dude
he looks like a killer you see him on
the street you ain't doing [__] I'm not
fighting next how much does he weigh not
260. yeah I mean he he also he weighed
after weigh-ins the next day he was two
220 yeah 2 30. you got like what 24 25
pounds that's been yeah man I did one
day of weight cutting I was trying to
get an influencer boxing card
the grind bro that was close bro Misfits
eight I was this close to being which
one it was me it was happy punch
playlist for keemstars thing yeah okay
and so um Kim's a man but like me and
this kid we're gonna fight we've been
trying for months and Keem was like I we
might be able to do it because the fight
fell off so I'm saying slowing down
fella sorry I don't interrupt you okay
there's that left hook
um but I was cutting weight and I had to
do Anthony's Gig up in Milwaukee so I'm
cutting weight trying to travel I
dropped like three four pounds and then
this kid kick out this kid texts me he's
like yo fight's off I haven't eaten in
two days I'm like all right dude how
much weight did you cut I cut like three
or four pounds so the thing was it
wasn't that yeah so you took a [__]
what the [__] I hadn't eaten for that I
had like drinking water that's all you
did you stopped you only got three
pounds not eating in two years
really tired listen games now it's about
to knock him out
John's really tired you said that round
two Brad you said that round too yeah
I'm telling you man
remember y'all not so 40 fellas exactly
without uppercuts oh yeah oh yeah oh
yeah come on yes dude this native South
American is throwing balls
figure out the
I don't like that's not what you want to
do if you're young oh what the [__] oh
yance kind of [__] he's tired bad body
language bad yeah look at that language
oh wow that's 40. welcome to 40.
dude Alex is looking good so you give
Alex that first or second round first
round yawn I think I I bet if it went to
bed I think Alex finishes him in this
third yeah if he can keep it up yeah
yeah because and also Jan's tired so
those double legs are coming from far
out he's gonna have the same strength
he's tired dude
oh dude UFC is going Sizzler Alex wins
this fight the Yuri fights [__] huge
tomorrow every fight's here Johnny
Walker Every fight
and then if you get that Artisan you put
a rematch for a belt potentially dude
that does two mil two mil pay-per-view
dude if Izzy beats do policies what else
does he have at middleweight what are
you gonna do if he beats the police he's
Strickland I don't think they're doing
well do polices got hurt yeah and then
they're not doing Strickland that
fight's in like six weeks Sean's been
saying it's not gonna happen yeah the
UFC doesn't want him to be champ it
feels like whoa shocking the guy who has
some of the most polarizing opinions
like we're good
we have sponsors
we're gonna go talk to manscapes
netscape's not all in on this they're
not all in on DeShawn they heard what
you said about women they're gonna pass
and they said he's a phenomenal fighter
though Sean's in it he is one of the
most unique unique guys of all time and
that's like his fighting style as well
it's so like close chested and Jab
oriented I love it he's a John's about
to get knocked out here fellas yeah I
feel that coming unless he lands like a
sloppy double leg here he's about to get
knocked out
come on I love how they're like remember
that above sea level it's like all right
here's what you are they're
professionals
yeah John's so tired I could see a head
kick with that big dome [__] oh do you
think you'd be massive he knocks this
dude oh
yeah remember that polish Powers no
pause legendary babe
it's I remember Yaya Rodriguez his
training camp for Volk he was in like an
Aztec Temple for six weeks and it was
like at elevation he was locked for for
weeks like an old school straight up
straight up it was bad yeah dude
how did you hit that dog we filmed an
Apocalypto here so yeah
Mel Gibson had to be on site during the
training camp
um
no that is a good question
Apocalypto is such a good movie
Alex just went like this like that's it
let's go yeah he just needs to land one
right in that big ass polish face that's
what I'm saying bro I feel like one left
hooks game
they both look pretty tired John looks
more tied though yeah I agree they're
both fatigued but Young's so tired I
feel bad for young because like that
Margaret on Goliath fight he was tearing
magomet's legs up yeah yeah and then
until I ever remembered he could wrestle
and just [__] yawn up the last two I
think no shame on him he's a great
fighter you gotta you got to take a bit
of a hike Bud we got so many fun
matchups that was Strikers down don't
don't [__] this up
same thing with Alexander rockitch you
know what I'm saying like he after
knocking out Jimmy Manawa I thought yo
this guy's the next big thing and then
he just wrestle [__] the next three
people and I was like I'm good if you
never fight again
which is training my gym all the time
man Rockets does no matter what man was
the man Jimmy man monster boy
bro challenge him in the street fighter
let me know how it goes
cannons
yon don't you take him down come on yes
[__]
[__] he's so tight off that takedown
let's go Alex Oh that polish Powers
there
I think I I agree with Brad I think
they're both just [__] exhausted yeah
that's why I'd be pissed I was a fighter
and they're like You Salt Lake City like
God damn it I'm in [__] Brazil That's
why Derek threw that flying me I'm
either getting it now by the UFC the
UFC's like dude it's that elevation so
you got a hot two minutes
[__] I do you think they did that on
purpose yes I do because they're like
You Gotta Get Off You Gotta yeah they're
like you gotta go because otherwise so
take his time doesn't want to be there
we'll sit back on his foot Derek Lewis
going forward is a problem backwards
nightmare for him he didn't fight well
going backwards I will say this I mean
he always throws those unconventional
strikes like I remember him throwing
switch kicks against Daniel Cormier at
UFC 230. you know he did against Matt
Mitchell remember Matt defended with his
hip and knocked him out
and I think it was England you know the
elevation [__] is really looking like
it's wearing on these guys when they do
Mexico City when they do Kane versus
redo Mexico City's higher than this dude
yo I'm curious bro UFC no we had three
UFC Champions who's been isania in Gano
we never got to UFC Africa what do you
think about that I think it's tough down
I think the politics are really tough
and like it's a big crooked down there
too so UFC probably looked into it and
then they're like trying to like there's
corruption in Nigeria yeah
we're good
because France says that he wanted to do
it too I just I think it's the politics
down there too too tough
damn they figured out in Brazil though
so I don't know they figure out in the
Middle East for God's sakes price dude
on Russia Island
that's so nice out there I've seen the
infrastructure you've been there
God damn it let's go see but if he
doesn't do anything with this you give
Piero that this third round it was a
close round
you're right I'm biased it was a close
round right that's right here
I'm too biased
that's why I like to win because there's
so many fun matches oh dude I agree with
you man Alex is a he's a he's a fun
fighter they're both so tired that
takedown was so weak damn dude how is
Yas Island that's [__] insane we
interviewed uh
Islam and uh we did I did the full sent
pod okay you went down there yeah we
interviewed how'd you get down there
what I'm saying the private Plans
by ship no private plane or did you fly
like united we did Emirates oh yeah
that's like a hotel in the air yeah
first class and that's like [__]
beautiful that's like the bed right you
get the bad yeah you have your own
little life it's like a condo yeah you
have a little pod it's really nice you
have a living room and [__] he's
literally an apartment yeah there's a
kitchen how long were you down there
though uh maybe like a week a little
more than a week
it was fun should have stayed for longer
because that jet lag was insane I bet
dude what was the hour differential
between where you're at it's days isn't
it is it like a Tuesday there right now
yeah yeah like 17 and 16 hours something
yeah that jet Link's no point Punk
that's like uh Australia man yeah [__]
me up for like like four or five days
and then you have to come back yeah it
was it was bad it was like right when
you were good and we were released did
you get to go out down there
I mean
we had yeah I could have went I we never
I didn't go out I don't really ever go
out to be honest really yeah I'm not I'm
not a lot of boys want to go either was
Steve with you yeah you guys just chill
in the hotel yeah we just like street
fights it yeah it's some Street Fighters
you cannot street fight out there yeah
dude
women can't even sneeze
that's honestly so safe it's insane
you're just like I heard but yeah if
you're a white boy and you [__] up game
you're screwed right oh you can't do you
can't steal like a Snickers they're like
chop your arms yeah [__] your arm you
know it's that eye for an hour Legend I
don't know I heard it's lit out there
it's amazing it's too far though it's
very far it's it's it's pretty in its
own way but like it's very flat you know
have you done uh like to buy Abu Dhabi
well Abu Dhabi is yes Island oh I heard
Dubai's Vegas on steroids I feel like
it's like yeah Dubai's fun it's cool but
it's it's it's it's kind of like Vegas
or you only want to go there for a
certain amount of time I'm good for a
day in Vegas yeah so you want to say one
night you'd want to spend more time in
Dubai but like not the car's in Dubai
well everyone's just super rich it seems
like I don't know nuts everyone Split
Decision I can see that
I give it to Alex
I'm biased though
yeah yes
yes
split yeah all my guys of winning did I
make a bet with you about beloved no you
didn't no no yeah fair enough
I mean uh yawns on a tough one right now
that's a bummer dude for you it was
honestly it was a really competitive
fight it was more it could have went
either way no one got robbed yeah
definitely if you told me Alex win by a
decision I'd say you're out of your
[__] I think if Yan had gotten to
take down maybe a minute earlier and was
a little bit more active on time he went
game he did last 30 seconds not a lot of
damage there yeah he's got arresting
I thought I thought Alex did enough in
that there dude Alex first of all has 10
fights eight and two and just beyond it
like heavyweight isn't that ridiculous
that's how talented that naughty natsos
I'll I I will um I'll say this one of
the big props about that one I think is
getting up in round number two
that's insane also defending the entire
first round with a [__] that body
lock and look so let's look at his UFC
run
Andres michelaidis Bruno Silva who's a
beast shot dominated him uh arasania
then lost fastest title shot ever I
wasn't hating on him I was like man this
is weird you that we can see what's
going on so him and his coach got mad at
me they said some [__] but it wasn't
hand on Alex I was just saying like it's
quick it's actually just jump the cue
which all good he deserved he beat Alex
you gotta think quemil Otani getting
that sub in 2015 is like yo that's my
career achievement bro
homeboys
oh boy's like that one's on the shelf
right now oh I'm putting that on up
but I mean he's and and he seems like a
really fun guy like I've seen him in a
lot of uh dude he's great for the
division too like they need the UFC need
him to win John's done his thing he's
been champ he's had his run he's 40. for
Alex there's so many [__] dope
matchups dude and there's that
Redemption
um or no not necessarily Redemption
sorry but like Glover beating young now
Alex beating young bro like the the
Protege it's a good storyline I like
that
um that's a good let's take a look at
that middle or sorry 205 division Yuri
Yuri versus Alex is the fight that's
[__] should wait two years ready to go
yo Nikita cry love is a beast so just
think about this uh yeah Yuri you got
um krylov you got racket you got Johnny
Walker Anthony Smith he got Lionheart up
in the mix so many dope fights
like stylistically so fun Paul Craig
too much Grandpa wait time out Paul
Craig wins at 185 and they reward him
with a move up but he's top 10 at
middleweight though and one win and they
jumped oh wait did he well I thought he
I thought he cut down I thought he came
down to middleweight because oh you're
right yeah so he went from yeah and so
they gave him a boost that light heavy
they have him ranked at middle no I
don't think he's ranked the middle no
not yet that's hilarious that's what I'm
thinking so yeah so he's nine so he
beats one guy yeah it's weird they still
haven't been there he looks [__] good
at middleweight he did he called out Bo
nickel dude I love that fight I love
that fight I do and I it depends what
the UFC wants to do because yeah Bo at
the world champion written all over him
but it just you know he thought that guy
was cutting Lawns and fought the next
day hey Val Woodburn Val wood burns the
he's the go
you go from that to Bow nickel then also
you know like for Bo Nicholas like you
go from that guy to [__] Paul Craig's
of savage but here's the thing you beat
Jamal Hill dude nickel I think this
would be his third UFC fight again
clearly they're Expediting him Paul
Craig called him out Paul wants that
smoke I say everyone wants that smoke
though it's kind of like like well no
who's calling out bow nickel so many
guys want him but but Nick is calling it
hamza's down too I don't like that one I
don't I don't like that one right now I
like that one maybe like a year from now
that's my boy year and a half
15 year old pregnant let's not talk
about it what
fact still has the statue
that's interesting
shame on you Carl he was young was he 15
no he was 20 something he was in college
he was 14 or 15. dark side of the
mailman I know the mailman's delivering
I was like maybe I'll give him an out
maybe he was 15 as well no no he's older
Dustin
it's been a good card man although that
Alex Pier One I did not see it going
that way decision Alex Pierre and
there's grappling listen baby we at
elevation I know this is what happens in
Salt Lake City
if Joseph Smith
if he didn't establish the Mormon
tradition here they wouldn't be so high
up
oh I can't wait for this fight oh you
got Kamari we got an update on Crawford
and uh
Georgie
spoiler alert on uh Crawford and Earl
Spence three two one
yeah seven Crawford's up pretty good
Crawford probably again in the seventh
so you're dropping the second and the
seventh so those are ten eights and he's
winning the other rounds
five minutes six five or six but two of
those five or six or ten eights oh
he's the number one pound for pound for
a reason he's straight out oh [__] that
movie looks dope this is a fight that I
think people have been in the boxing
Community have wanted for you it's three
years too late but still they're both
not as bad not as bad not as bad like
they're both still in their prime one
guy's the pound for pound number one
another guy's I think number four pound
per pound it should happen three years
ago then Earl Spence in the car crashes
God damn so he's piecing him up he's
cooking he's cooking they're both making
bank though
Brandon I'm curious
[Laughter]
traditional martial arts The Art of War
if you will which when you like
subscribe to some Sun Tzu type [__]
I don't subscribe to that no no because
I because I didn't come up in like that
traditional like martial arts like to me
it was just an athletic competition
let's view it as martial arts probably
would have been better if I had that
channel like the GSP like martial arts
you were just more like I'm gonna beat
the phone that stuff was just kind of
gay
reading no man
that's for the for the theater kids dude
like the gsps and like those those guys
that channeled that I I think it was
almost this is almost like the guys that
like had God on their side like the real
religious guys who are like praying or
you like how how's this fighting girl
it's in God's hands I was like I'm so
jealous I'm not religious I'm not a
martial artist an athlete that no other
options you know
what um [__] okay I think I've I don't
remember it exactly but college football
NFL yeah you were on the training team
or not travel Bills Buffalo Bills yeah
uh Camp the [__] happened training camp
yeah yeah uh pull the hamstring got cut
no I could then I could have went I had
offers from like Miami the Dolphins the
Jets but I realized I'm like I'm just
gonna be like a guy like I'm not gonna
be the guy like I might be a practice
squad guy I gotta move on with my life
that's fair yeah I respect that yeah I
feel like a lot of people in that
situation would have taken the practice
squad for sure a lot of guys do and then
some make it most don't you know so
you're just like this practice squad guy
people like oh but you're in the NFL
you're making millions like no this
practice squad guys make like 70 G's
yeah I had a degree double major so I
was like I gotta move on Doug what was
your least favorite college course
it was like this weather it was like I
think it was something in weather but it
was like a science weather class it was
so [__] boring too like all the
different clouds and like yeah like
[__] I don't want to be Kathy Saban on
nine news
the whole semester of like weather
you're like oh my God how did you end up
in that [__] class dog it was it was
it was one of the requisites I had to
have
business and sociology and I had to have
one of those electives and that yeah I
was like oh whether that be easy oh my
God is that so boring dude I gotta my
only C in college was astronomy because
I did like an expedite it was like a
seven week instead of a 15 week and it
was all physics and that was it was I
was online and I was like I thought this
was gonna be about stars yeah this is a
night dude I got these on every test I
majored in finance oh yeah um so same
thing I was like I just need this for
like it's weird elective yeah straight
up everyone was like take astronomy it's
easy and I'm like
I'm kidding it bro I wish I majored in
history because I loved like I remember
my favorite class was ancient Rome in
history that was dope yeah yeah it was
dope who was so useless dude oh the way
they taught it was just this is not the
way to go what did you major in
business management
because I dropped out oh [__] well there
you go
Community College going to Community
College I went to Sac State for one year
then I went to Community College in San
Francisco
um uh where I'm from and then I hit you
up for street fighting yeah got kicked
off the street right now and I went down
to uh Cal State Fullerton school great
baseball yeah and then I just I just
remember it was like a certain amount
and then it just got more and more
expensive and then I just couldn't pay
for it and I was like whoop can't go
anymore debt this is a terrible idea
it's a scam man it's a scam
but it's a scam that Millions accept I
didn't use any of it it's just part of
the cult like no one even questions it
now people are starting to well people
are starting to I think in like a
professional setting especially like
business it's still so valued to it can
get your foot in the door if you don't
have a no because they residents like a
legit school too yeah yeah yeah yeah you
can't if you don't have the paper you
don't have that [__] on paper people
won't even you can see why like you
can't be some high school dropout then
applying that [__] you know some
Fortune 500 company listen I've watched
enough suits to realize
when Mike Russo walks in the door
I know I know you're not Mark Zuckerberg
Mark's 101. you are
my thing with business now it's like
business in general and school in
general it's like it's such a different
space now than it was like I know I was
looking back and they have like Majors
for like
uh like internet marketing and it's like
who's teaching that I want to know who's
teaching that class because it's so
brand new yeah yeah
if it's not Mr Beast get the [__] right
can you imagine we should be first day
but that's how you know it like I
remember I don't know how many years ago
it was but like somewhere in the last 10
years it was like social media like
internet marketing it's like who the
[__] teaching that because we're all
still learning it yeah like I'm still
learning it some six-year-old professors
just like so I was like we can make
money off this make that a class that's
how you know it's [__] yeah stupid
that's like well I not to [__] on web3
at all because maybe there's
applications but like every web three
person I've talked to I've like asked
them to describe it to me in the easiest
way possible and I've never come away
understanding anything about web3 and
I'm like you not understand about it
what the [__] is it
let's start there well it's just an
heart yeah the hell is it
yeah I mean I'm not an expert but I'm
just it's it's like it's like [__] a
space where I'm assuming the different
processing systems different [__] like
that like we talk about using Bitcoin
instead of like using traditional
banking well there's like decentralized
but like I don't I don't understand how
that's webbed through I understand how
that's like my blockchain or like crypto
I can get behind that but like when
people say I'm a web three marketing
specialist I'm like
what yeah who's teaching that dark web
class though yeah
[Laughter]
yeah I'll be loaded up on passports man
like all your teachers are in cells
you ready to lose money [__] yeah no
saying a little more quiet because I'm
like I bet then geez against goddamn
just engage who's a Savage also trains
with my old coach so that's fine I
checked how's his second fighter ever
what that's [__] bananas dude it was
me and Shane Carwin started with him
before us it was Nate Mark cart Shane's
a dog yeah but it means Shane car went
together did you okay so with Trevor is
he always like a robot or does he is he
like a you know no he's always like the
happiest person yeah like smiling no
matter what yeah when you're losing you
lose five seconds okay
you're like no it's not dude he's like
it's off it's fine you're like you're
like dude I just lost I have a
concussion dude I made eight grand I
have to pay you seven it's not okay when
you see the memes of like Trevor Whitman
cage side like smiling I haven't seen
him but he's always but I haven't seen
the memes I'm not on the social media
that much I guess actually it's like
logic bald though but um he was always
look at him he's right behind gaichi's
neck behind there he is with the glasses
we always made fun of trump because I
have a bunch of fight picks like it's
like me like pacing like a lion and then
all the coaches are like oh seriously
you see each other smiling yeah Lisa
always make fun of them yeah it's a meme
now because he does it in Camaro's
corner just engages everything because
he's just happy to be he's like to him
it's a celebration because they put in
all this work he's like yeah we're here
like whatever happens we're here that's
interesting Trevor's a great coach what
about the Onyx gloves because he's got
the curve dude he's uh you know I've
known Trevor for 20 years he was talking
about his making custom like he was
making his own custom clubs give him to
us like back in the day so now he's made
a business like yeah he knows the [__]
Brad Martin about to lose 10 G's I can't
wait to win that here's the question
here's the question Father Time catches
up to everybody does it catch up to
Justin get you tonight after all these
wars he's been in they're only 30. that
lows 34 but in dog years he's 70. that
guy he just hit a cartwheel bro
trust me he's good that's why I brought
that up that cartwheel was not good
yeah bro that was like me doing a car he
was vertical for a second but his feet
were like this yeah in their training
camper I saw him do like a double back
handspring or some [__] like no he's a
mother's backflips he just uses
wrestling I think I think we're getting
more grappling I think Dustin poi
dominates him on the ground I think
she's Jujitsu is Tori Black Poirier at
any range whether it's phone booth or at
distance I think Poirier dominates I
think if they want to Grapple if they're
clinching Poirier in the first fight was
so much stronger in the clinch and on
the exit bro Corey was touching him on
the brake so I just can't like again for
people that watch the first fight
explain to me what Justin gaichi does
and how he does it better than important
because that first fight is not it was
it was competitive but in terms of like
closeness
but I also think Corey watches I was
like right that was a dog fight could
make this easier I'm gonna use more
grappling grappling is maybe a
two-stripe white belt on the ground I'm
a black belt I'm gonna use that more to
my advantage he hates being down there
even though I don't submit him the first
round he knows the takedown that's gonna
open up my striking so I think we're
getting a little more grappling out of
this gentleman right here I agree with
you completely and I'll say this it just
goes out and slob or not
um no the first five teachers because
like gaichi and not even in the poorier
fat but like every UFC fight he Ducks
down so much yes and for me I was like
when I watched it I'm thinking if
Poirier just grabs because that collar
tie a little tie clinch yeah
dog in the tie clinch man
come on
like right now how much you weigh I mean
bro
I mean listen I think that's a
no-brainer I think we know the answer to
that I don't know
I mean I mean just get I mean you could
just guess like obviously you're active
on Twitter when you said you were coming
on the show where people like oh call
Bradley out was there that [__] or no
there were a lot of people that were
like yeah you should get bread you
should get Bradley some [__] and I was
like all right I love it that's why I
did my research baby yeah I dig it it's
good
it doesn't pour His tan yeah he's been
he's been on you guys want spoiler alert
on the boxing match Crawford finished
them what round JJ he's stopping the
knife yeah could we could we get the
finish up on this TV wow oh my really
I'm sure there's highlights you could
bring up on Instagram can we get the
finish right here no don't bring up on
the screen well then I can see the
screen anyways just bring it up on here
yeah please I want to peek it what a
[__] showing by Crawford yeah I was
always the debate always the debate but
all the boxing heads are like not butts
too talented man dominant bro this is
one
Nebraska is the best base for Combat
Sports
if you're from Nebraska who else is out
of Nebraska nobody
absolutely nobody one guy you know who's
from Nebraska uh it might be Kansas City
but uh I think Anthony Smith is from
Nebraska he's not from Nebraska he reps
Nebraska but he's from
um like [__] Chicago or some [__] are
you sure let's Google it does he live in
Nebraska he lives okay no I because I
looked this yes I'm tired of Nebraska
because he fights out of Nebraska he
wraps it but he's not from Nebraska
he's a Nebraska boy
born in Corpus Christi Texas oh that's
right but fighting out of Omaha
he's repping it yeah but he's like he's
still not from there that's true yeah
you're right you can't you can't inject
Nebraska fighting inside somebody you
know what I'm saying about Nebraska is
known for football even though they suck
from bloody elbow but Nebraska
cornhusers haven't been good you should
go to Twitter well Scott Frost I mean
yeah no nuke a piece of [__] yeah you'll
find her on Twitter he's going to run
this [__] is that still your phone
number so Spence Crawford yeah
it'll you'll fit you'll find it
chill sun and fatigue is not a criteria
well yeah yeah
oh here we go
oh damn his face is jacked bro whoa
oh they stopped it there kind of like
yeah they should have especially wow
because it looks like he's getting his
[__] his face is beat up
he dropped them twice before this too in
this world another day with Spence
having like any success his face says
you drop them around around money and
then after that was downhill God damn
damn this is Total Domination
wow good thing I didn't pay for it yeah
right it was just this bro I still pay
for it my girls watch it right now I got
[__]
she text me yes you did did you see you
again recorded [__] I don't know how to
pronounce his name and I feel horrible
about it but now nayoi inui yeah
most people don't know who he is but
he's the number one I mean number one
guy but that guy should be in the
conversation because I think he's so
young in like the pro boxing career but
he's beating like but he's awesome tiny
then he looks like he belongs in BTS
look at that [__] Savage could
use a better haircut
though but it's big over there right
like the red tips dying your hair is big
but red I see a lot of red like I mean
Fiesta's red frosted tips yeah it's
awesome that he wanted right when
Oppenheimer dropped that was a good win
excuse me
was like this is his media team was like
they were like down bro Oppenheimer
ain't the only thing dropping tonight
like hey dropped off and have yourself
Brad's like now Jesus Christ
I like those I love those jokes
people think he's the best
this guy oh yeah yeah he's like most
like real he's number one yeah
ever's aggressive because like people
were talking about him like they talked
about Vasily lomachenko a couple years
back it's just I feel the same
conversation is occurring he has like a
the majority of his wins or Knockouts
like he has like four wins but he's
undefeated like yeah what does he weigh
damn
and that's people were talking about
like him in uh Manny Pacquiao and I feel
like it's not fair to compare because
Pacquiao is like a young dude that was
cutting to that weight class 9 is like
30 right yeah yeah he's not gonna get to
one oh this is here you know what I mean
yeah exactly like those comparisons it
pissed me and there's no stars in his
division like Manny Pacquiao had some
[__] dogs
Miguel Cotto yeah
tank yeah
oh Brian oh Espinoza or Brian Daly
wait so is Maxwell presenting the BMF
though yeah he's gonna wrap around the
yeah is he gonna unbutton further or is
he just going like that was a lot of
hair you know what I'm saying it kind of
makes sense it's all doing it not the
rock things
here's what but on the street didn't
they not like that the UC audience not
like that the Rock by UC audience you
mean me and you mean us I mean he played
for reals Brad you and The Rock in a UFC
cage who wins I got Brad oh man I would
play football Miami I would love that I
mean he weighs the same same way as you
right 40.
he's up there he has to be 260. he's
also 50 something
I would love to do that now you're both
gonna piss hot
oh he's dead 260. oh [__] dude on the
dot baby
bad news Brad Martin right there it's a
little it's a little it's a little dicey
I take that fight though how much was
Lesnar Lesnar was like what 267. no look
let's have to cut to 65 yeah
before like massive
let's go I'm taking Dustin already just
by that sharp Dustin's a Savage both
both these are high level [__] here I'm
trying to come oh that's okay yeah not a
lot when Dustin pulls out them shorts
though enjoy game enjoy the night adjust
the hair yeah enjoy the night yeah
telling you Brad if he pulls up them
shorts when he's in the middle of
fisticuff my 10 G is good as gold really
yep I only see him he pulls him up oh he
just did it no no you know because it's
different you'll know it's an aggressive
pull
I'm trying to comprehend that there is
ten thousand dollars on the line between
you guys right now I know I was trying
to forget about it sorry no let me not
bring it up again
and figure it out in this one
this one which is just tough he's just
such a wild card and he throws like a
madman so it's tough to plan for
I would say Dustin's crisper boxing who
do you give the power to I think they're
equal in power because like the thing
with power is a little more explosive
well here's it's explosive but power is
a lot about placement and Poirier is a
tactician at places to be accurate yeah
like power power doesn't get you much
when you're partially connecting like
gaichi does all the time Fair Point sir
and when guys like Edson to your point
you say you remember how you're talking
about how he keeps leaning down you're
gonna take advantage of that amen I
think if he gets those counter types
there's a knee he's fainting it it's in
their first fight kicks there too you
know Edson and um like other guys they
would circle out and get you would catch
him with power their first fight when
Poria would circle out bro hand up
you're not catching him there's no
openings for gaichi to land
these guys are fun to watch though oh
this is really good yeah dude this is a
[__] BMF title baby how do you guys
think about the uh the names on the
canvas you pay a thousand dollars or
whatever it is and you get your name on
the canvas
so look at those names on that black
line so people pay five hundred dollars
on there you can get your [__] name
like no welcome welcome back to the UFC
Brandon shop UFC would not let me do
that
I was thinking it'd be funny did you
make it bigger so my friends can [__]
see it
and they're like they cut it out and
they send it to you oh that's clean
Dustin's acknowledging it that's not
great no we never got a knowledge is not
good
isn't it funny how the UFC's like man we
don't want all these logos on their
pants we're gonna put them on the
Octagon don't get me started
that shit's stupid I counted there were
over 36. oh that hurt his eye [__] him
up there was there were over 36 logos on
the canvas not even [__] [__] you
this whole thing was like we did they
just like NASCARs it looks
unprofessional and they put it on the
map yeah
Dustin's hands are high though so it's
good yeah but that's that it's that left
of gay Chi because like that movie left
that Philly shell like there is an
opening you know what I'm saying
do that see that I heard him oh see he
so you call it he keeps dipping down
they're taking advantage of it I'm the
greatest even if it's a coach ever even
it doesn't land it's still it's keeping
them busy
and that's I think about round one let's
keep them busy try to overload them
oh Big Shot
I got way too excited I'm so sorry [__]
dude I like it let's get more excited
baby come on all right let's get it
through the roof
I got to hear Bradley Martins how you
feeling about your bet Brad I feel good
about it yeah it's still I'm gonna yeah
it gets you so dangerous but I'm feeling
pretty good okay not great I'm feeling
good about it as soon as I said that big
red it's okay I feel great about our bet
yeah
I'm equally as invested did you just
slap it kind of slap what the [__] was
that Stockton little 209
yeah it keeps diving down here's the end
point stylistically it's an orthodox
versus a southpaw and Dustin is such a
dangerous Southpaw and I don't think
geichi has had much success with that
stance Clash you know and it really
affected them 28. to get these credit as
Whitman says he they are fighting
smarter here yeah that's true but if I'm
gaichi I'm jabbing man I'm I'm
establishing the piston and then setting
everything up off of that he's not
really he's just I was just gonna
mention he hasn't been throwing the leg
kicks like he's in 2018 but he just
threw that good luck kick there it's
where they went away from that even
though that's why I got him stop oh I
was going oh who gets right there get
out of there one round for the Deep for
my boy the deep penetration baby the DP
Bradley hey do you know about do you
feel good yeah I feel great man to be
honest yeah it's still up I mean this
one I'm a little I'm still up in the air
but I think there's Pizza
I mean I can he's oh I don't put Pizza
in this stuff a guy like me I'll eat a
couple slices
the turtlenecks are getting a little bit
tighter you know what I'm saying not
around
here look I got I gotta go up a size
oh man
it's not a good card man it's been a
great card yeah what a fun evening I
just want to win this money did you
finish a six-pack modeler I did you're
the goat I'm you really did you're the
goat bro I can finish six more if you
guys put him in front of me I wish did
we do we have more models
put every Modelo that we possibly have
in front of me right now the same as ASU
frat house this is listen I wasn't in
frat I was too good for it uh no I was
dude I was I was too involved did you
try out for him or no I accidentally
rushed I accidentally rushed Fiji you
just went to a party
and yeah he's coming in with the
modellas you're the [__] go baby I
think Bud Light owns Modell and they're
stocked through the roof and everyone's
like yeah take that Bud Light
we own them too dumbass
another six pack locked and loaded
we got Bud Lights too if you want one of
those I'll Crush any beer oh yeah you
drink Bud Light
Bud Light here's the thing Beer's beer
Beer's a beer at the end of the day I
like when people start sucking [__]
people like to attribute political
meanings to [__] beers beer at the end
yeah I agree come on real real
[__] they drink but not here
it's like I hear you Beals
little BL action I'll drink you put in a
glass can
put a little cup before you put
isn't it weird how that became a thing
and like I went to the Padres game right
and I'm there with my brother and my oh
oh no no no he knocked him out head kick
poya knockout the head kick yeah I mean
gaichi knocked him out
yes
let's go
run me my [__] money
oh my God I wish I missed that [__]
trying to get pizza I don't know bro I'm
so mad right now and you don't like
pizza bro
he's gone
we're never gonna know [__] dude [__]
he's never thrown a head kick ever yeah
well listen that's why I'm the [__]
I'm the commentator here boys
nothing's so upset yeah he should be
this is some hot hot sauce huh is it hot
yeah good hot sauce no I don't have my
own hot sauce that's Dustin's thing come
on
little shop songs I know the shop the
shop sauce
sexual thick you know we have uh we
should have pores hot sauce around here
let's get pourriate let's call him
I think so grab some of that grab that
grab that in honor of my man losing
that's not [__] DP on that run run
the sauce run the sauce I want to see
the replay though that'd be great if you
show us a [__] replay please wow was
he really out was that like he's out oh
dude wait till you see it I know we're
talking about Bud Lights and not being
gay but what's this look
his hand was still up it just got right
behind the air it was like uzman and
Edwards man it's like oozman and [__]
Edwards his hand was still up but oh
boom
legit that is [__] ridiculous wow
oh my God damn that's that [__] hey
you're like I feel so good you [__]
loser yeah man
that's fair oh my God
what do you do with Gates you know you
can't do you you can't do mock that was
a monkey beat the [__] out of him Darius
maybe get you Darius
yeah hey I feel great good Steve you owe
me five bucks [__]
God dog
wow folded him dude that is [__]
tough holy [__] dude if if if you would
have predicted gaichi by head kick oh
I'd love to hear the commentaries man
[__] man Rogan does not look that
surprised
you know how they usually do that thing
oh yeah whoa
like this whoa
what an epic [__] finish dude what a
card second round wow that was a great
card though dude great card that was a
banger a fun car got Vince Vaughn is my
little screenshot I was gonna ask you I
saw it I didn't want to call you out on
air why Vince Vaughn why the [__] he's
just a fan of them
it's events bro great guy come on yeah
he's [__] big and you know he does
Jiu Jitsu the Gracie Academy in Torrance
does he actually yeah that's [__]
sick stud let's go double feet yeah
they're [__] God [__] damn it dude
no I actually do want to know why you
know the difference is Camaro's hand
wasn't up hold on a second he didn't
really give a good explosion why Vince
I need to know why that's on your phone
I mean my girl and I broke up yesterday
so I was like I need this yesterday
I need something oh my God okay I need
somebody else and I'd rather look at
Vaughn wow
okay
Vince Vaughn's on there because my [__]
of a girlfriend I knew this was gonna go
somewhere I was like yeah I was gonna
let it go because no I wasn't because I
saw it when his phone first went off I'm
like man that's weird
but whatever guy out but it made no
sense I was waiting for someone to bring
it up I will say that I planted it was a
seed it was like the double turn like I
was like I thought you'd be like he's my
hero so I don't know nah bro I haven't
seen a Vince Vaughn movie in like five
years I don't think he's done one in
five years
but I just figure you're a big fan I
didn't think it was a girl broke up with
you
yes the best [__] right there
man Bradley Martin coming through the
play of the day there you go that is
ridiculous there was no grappling zero I
think that's a mistake emporia's part
wow
I feel really good about that you should
dude I didn't see that coming at all
dude that's gonna sting I need 10 grand
I feel great thank you too hey
I needed that five dollars
damn that was
a seems all right man yeah
he's alive
he's he's up
he's helping kicking [__] dude I know
dude I didn't see that going down I
don't know what do you do with gay team
man Darius I feel like Darius is the
only thing you can do because
by Oliveira yeah but he's coming off a
horrible loss Gage is coming off the
huge win but get you know you can do
loser winner listen
geichi was destroyed by Habib destroyed
by Charles I don't think that this fight
is title implications no no so I think
you do gaichi Darius and then if the
Islam Charles fight isn't clear or
whatever maybe you do gaichi versus
winner of
something else I don't know Jim bring up
the 55 rankings yeah hey my girl Diana
bobita how cold what's up baby cakes
uh uh yeah Darius at four come off a
loss yeah
because what are you gonna do Chandler
again you know what I'm saying so it's
got to be fizzy already It's gotta be
darush
that's not gonna happen
well maybe I I feel like dare you should
and I love dare use
dude Connor gaichi bro gate [__]
gaichi kills him well Conor McGregor
will legally be dead
nobody watched so many seasons of The
Ultimate Fighter the coaches don't fight
it's such a mistake it's stupid see that
one's different than the Usman one
because his hands yeah he saw it coming
but it was just too far out damn he went
sniper Adam when's the last time we saw
Dustin get flatlined like that 2017
against Johnson
I'm Michael Johnson is the last guy to
do that to [__] uh Dustin Poirier
yeah yeah you're right
I'm so upset right now boom all my five
dollars see how I feel I feel I feel
like it's over I hope that hot sauce
blows your ass off yeah it's [__]
it's almost like spicy and sweet
delicious I'll get the I'll get the
drinks tonight I'll get the rounds don't
worry brother
I'm so impressed that you're down in
these models you don't have to talk
about what you and your girl break up
man ah you know just [__] it's
incompatibility how old is she you're
also a jet Setter 13.
she's uh she's 20. okay
did she go to ASU still going
but yeah and you're doing your thing
you're jet setting you're really [__]
Colombia she's a great girl she's an
amazing girl yeah didn't work out that's
what it is how it goes
wow Justin gaichi man insane that's an i
really genuinely bro this entire [__]
week I've only envisioned a Dustin
Poirier win I I didn't even think I am
too yeah yeah I get locked in and I'm
like me too
man that's insane what a win for Safford
Arizona wow
felt it man
you know just when you know you know
how much you think gechu is right now
260. definitely not 260.
easy picking easy pickings for uh for
Bradley I just it yeah gaichi's in a
weird spot because he got destroyed by
Oliveira got destroyed by Mark Chev yeah
BB Poirier so he'll be number two Dairy
was coming off a horrible lost uh dude I
think beat fazive he's beat Chandler
gaichi dark yush is the move in my
opinion it's the only fight you can do
unless they want him to wait for the
winner of Market chapter dude you're
you're waiting nine to ten months in my
opinion because Oliver wouldn't be bad
for gay team it wouldn't be bad not for
sure I agree with that but like why not
get like a uh November little MSG versus
uh nothing about yeah Sarah bokonowski
[Applause]
that guy's amazing yeah easily one of my
favorite Fighters he's one of the
coolest people too we interviewed him
he's real nice you like that I think
volcanopsy piece GHC me too I think he
does too yeah yeah yeah I think
vocalypse beats my channel I think
Vulcan actually beats [__] bro
any fighter you know
and it gets bulked back in 155 gets him
a win you like that I like that I like
that it's a major fight because listen I
love Darius but he lost that big fight
it's not gonna sell oh he's coming off a
huge win we've talked about that the
difference is
it's side one's with the right side one
the hands open is up the other hand's
down it's a little different they're
just showing head kicks now yeah one was
at the last [__] just showing a
random he could be like it's exactly the
same
wow get you with me feeling so [__]
good man what a win
I'm peeing again what a win well we're
about to sign off dude oh fast you know
yeah before we take a [__] we'll keep it
here I love winning you should feel good
dude I feel great pizza keep that same
energy with Logan Paul Bro I feel great
all right Bradley with the hot sauce
October 14th
December we need December so my boy can
get his drink you're that hot sauce hot
as [__] history
you know what your kids my kid loves
that's why I knew because it's sugar bro
it's just sugar that's why I knew he's
gonna make all the money but it's not
sugar as much sugar as like Gatorade or
the other drinks or Kool-Aid or
something is that really yeah it's true
because it's like you're cooking water
yeah that's what I knew he's gonna make
all the money in the world because my
son was playing soccer and I brought
Gatorades like my my the parents turned
to buy the drink so it was my I was up
so I brought Gatorade it's like oh [__]
where's the
bro seven but that's when you know it's
big because they want Prime I'm like
girl you guys drink that [__] and
they love it that's what it means
audience too man it's tasty too that's
what Elite athlete strength is good
Prime
well I think that's it for us here I'm
in your neck the woods August 11th one
night two shows August 11th stand up
live Phoenix Arizona and then I uh also
in what are we in going into uh August I
will be in Omaha Nebraska one night only
on August 16th and then one night only
August 17th in Kansas City Missouri go
get your tickets thick boy.com for
Bradley Martin
all he sees is red that's it come at me
bro yep my boy Ben Davis you crushed it
man enjoy those modellas Bradley I owe
you a lot of money yep all right kids
love sleeping good tonight